a male chimp is more than enough to kill
any human on the planet including Gordon
Ryan so Gordon Ryan fighting a chimp a
good sized no a thousand times how many
times does he win he loses a thousand
times
it's not even competitive it's not even
remotely compared do you think he will
disagree
no
do you think anyone will disagree anyone
yeah [ __ ]
the following is a conversation with
John donaher his third time on this
podcast he's widely considered to be one
of the greatest Minds in martial arts
history
this is a Lex Friedman podcast to
support it please check out our sponsors
in the description and now dear friends
here's John donoher
the ADCC is the Premier submission
grappling tournament in the world we
just had it a couple of weeks ago we saw
many demonstrations of greatness from
athletes you coached but a year ago
the team and you were at a very low
point
take me through that Journey what was
the lowest point we had a very very
tight team for many years which began in
New York City during the peak of covid
training in New York became very
difficult to sustain so most of the team
despised the city of New York I I was
the only person in the group that liked
living in New York
um I think part of the problem was that
I was the only one who actually lived in
Manhattan the others had to commute to
New York and there's a world of
difference between living in New York
and commuting to New York so most of
them had a very negative view of New
York City
that was compounded by covid uh when
even the basic Act of training became
very very difficult and uh so everyone
decided they want to leave so there was
a prospect of
a complete breakup between myself and
the team or I would have to leave New
York there was a difficult decision for
me to make as I lived in New York for 30
years
um I had built my life there and had
most of my friends and Associates that I
know here in America with New Yorkers
so I thought you know these guys have
been unstained uh incredibly loyal to me
as students so
I should also be loyal to them of course
so I decided that if they wanted to
leave I would go with them we decided uh
to go to Puerto Rico because there was a
a private gym where we could train
through the covert period
um I personally wanted to go to Texas I
thought that Texas was a better place
for the team to go but many of the
students including senior students like
Gordon Ryan Craig Jones had been to
Puerto Rico and stayed with one of the
head officials of ADCC Mo Jason
so uh they loved their experience in
Puerto Rico and uh almost everyone
wanted to go down there
so I tried to explain to him there's a
world of difference between going to a
place for vacation versus living there
but that didn't
have any effect so the decision was made
a majority decision was made to go to
Puerto Rico
um
in Puerto Rico the conditions in which
the team lived changed significantly
when you're in New York New York is such
a big city that if there's any
uh tension between team members and and
everybody there will be in a competitive
sport where everyone's fighting each
other you can kind of bury them in the
size of the city because there's so many
distractions in New York you know you
come and you do your workout you go
outside and it's New York City
um in Puerto Rico we lived in a very
small uh local Town Dorado and most of
the athletes were living with each other
and so unlike New York where there was
always a break you trained together but
when training was over you went about
your life in New York and New Jersey
um with everyone living in very close
proximity to each other any tensions
got magnified because there was no
relief from them you didn't get to get
away from people if you had a problem
with someone on the mat well now you had
to to live with them for uh the rest of
the day and the night and this goes on
for long periods of time so I believe it
had the effect of magnifying whatever
tensions there were in particular there
was a uh a family tension between two
brothers which magnified over time
um
uh and you know as so often as the case
you get two brothers growing up one
older one younger and the younger one
wants to
grow and uh and feel somewhat like a
young tree underneath a bigger tree and
um uh sometimes people just need their
space so there was there was some
unhappiness and um as a younger brother
I can understand yeah yeah there's a
little tree that had to grow up under a
bigotry yeah so um [ __ ] the big tree
there's a lot of aggression
unresolved family issues
I love you he doesn't he's lying
so uh as time went by these these
tensions started uh increasing they came
to a point where
um it was difficult for them even to be
in the training room together at that
point you're starting to you know when
Once training takes a hit then you
you've got to start to address these
um the attempts at reconciliation
uh fell through and uh
a decision was made to to move to Texas
I wanted everyone to move as a team
what I wanted to do was keep the team
together
as long as the period leading up to 80cc
so that everyone could train together
so I said okay there's problems but
let's just tough it out one year we
moved to Texas
let's just go there and keep Unity if
some people don't want to train with
other people that's fine but I believe
that the team would be weakened by
breaking apart I believe that they had
an excellent Rapport as training
Partners the technical level was
increasing dramatically
many of the younger athletes are really
starting to come into their own and
really develop well and so my take on it
was okay if there's problems
so be it but let's all just stay
together until 80cc 2022 was a unified
team go out prepare yourselves as best
you can and
um uh and then after that we can make a
decision as to whether we break up or
not
um but that was rejected and uh the team
split and
um uh they moved to Austin uh We've made
prior arrangements to go to a local gym
and they took that jam and uh we were
left with no gym and more or less
homeless in uh in Austin so uh a year
out from ADCC yes this is one year out
so roughly three quarters of the uh
competitive athletes left in in one week
um so uh at that point uh that was
probably the lowest point because at
that point not only did we not have a
place to train
um we had very few training partners for
the few that had remained
and um uh the main athlete in the team
Gordon Ryan was going through a
particularly bad spell with his
unresolved stomach issues and there was
doubt as to whether or not he could
compete at all and was actively thinking
about retiring from the sport so maybe
not compete ever again potentially yeah
yeah so that was a time when he's like
man this is the whole program seems to
be dead in the water at this point
um most of the competitive athletes were
gone there were very few training
partners for the few that remained and
the main athlete around whom the group
had initially bonded
um was seemingly out of action possibly
permanently
where is your mind or were you mentally
my my thinking is
everything bad passes in time I've had a
lot of bad points in my life so um uh my
life experiences whenever things seem
dark
have patience time will ultimately cure
most ills not all of them but most of
them and
um uh I'm confident that if you give me
a new crop of students I can
I can produce magic but it's going to
take time so that conference was in part
a source of strength yes it's just like
I I wasn't confident that ADCC 2022
would go well because we only had one
year without a gym and with a team that
was completely broken up to um to to
even an attempt to get into ADCC
so um uh things looked a little Grim but
I was confident you know given enough
time I get in a new uh group of students
and and work
um as it turns out uh one of
the uh demonstration partners that uh I
used during filming for instructional
videos who lives in Boston uh John Carla
badoni was interested in the idea of
coming down and training but he'd always
felt like it would be difficult because
there were people in his weight class
who were already there and he felt it
would be awkward
um but now that they had left that
opened up an area for him so he was the
first one to come down he moved from
Boston to um uh Austin Texas
I began teaching at a local school it
was rather like going back into my
earliest days in judici I went from
teaching at the big henzo Gracie Academy
to a tiny school in Puerto Rico and now
an even smaller School in Austin Texas
and locals would come in and train and I
would watch every day teaching their
twice a day seven days a week and I
would see people come in and train and I
would say this guy has some potential
this guy has some potential and I would
recruit people and bring them to another
gym where they would train with the
professionals and if they proved adapt
and hardworking and someone who can work
well in a team they would stay and build
their skills as time went by
um more and more such people started
coming in and we had some remarkable
people like a young South African purple
belt Luke Griffith came in he had lost
in the European trials for ADCC and he
was down on his luck he came into Austin
he did a show against a local purple
about and lost again so he was a
uh feeling bad about his performance in
his future and he came in and I thought
he was a lovely kid who worked hard and
trained well
um so he became one of the main training
partners he was similar size to Gordon
so I encouraged him to train with with
Gordon whenever he could
and he more and more people started
coming into the train under that kind of
basis
um one day I got a text from uh Gordon
who was filming an instructional video
in Boston he said hey you know Nicholas
murugali was training at this he was
shooting video at the same time as me
and we we just uh did some grappling
he's a really nice guy and he's
literally never trained with without a
gear before he's for those of you who
don't know Nicholas murugali is a one of
the outstanding gee Jiu Jitsu
competitors of his Generation
Um has an amazing game and is a
superstar with the uh the ghee side of
the sport but it never even trained
without a ghee once in his life so his
first ever
no ghee training session is with Gordon
Ryan the best no geek competitor of all
time and I remember Gordon texting me
saying he's really talented he's a nice
guy and um he wants to come down to
Texas and train so yeah sounds great so
over time just more and more people
started coming in and
um uh I told everyone like you guys are
at a severe disadvantage like you're
you've got very little time to get ready
for ADCC Luke wasn't even an ACC had to
win trials same for uh Dan manisoy who
he had failed at trials and needed to
get a win to even get into ADCC
so around this time a doctor suggested
by Moe jasm who had himself had stomach
issues earlier in his life began working
with Gordon Ryan and Moe's the organizer
of ADC yes
he's the uh the head organizer
um he
was able to get Gordon Ryan not cured
but significantly better than he was
before and
to a level where Gordon could could
train up to five to six days a week
and it was a big Improvement on what was
going on during the end of the time in
Puerto Rico
so things started moving we had a core
group of athletes uh training at a local
gym
which was very very generously offered
to us by uh
the head manager of Roca sunglasses a
company here in Austin Texas they have a
private corporate gym which we were able
to train in
and these talented youngsters from
around the globe essentially came
together and I said you guys are gonna
have to train harder than you've ever
trained in your life because you've got
less time to get ready for this than
anyone and uh you're going to be going
up against people potentially who
know exactly what I teach because I've
been teaching them a lot longer they've
been teaching you in addition to the
other best people in the world so it was
a uh an incredible challenge for them
and I must say all of them
gave literally everything they had
everything I asked for they gave twice
as much and um we had a crazy training
schedule as many as three classes per
day I know that sounds easy you know
three classes a day but try doing it
sometime these classes are not your
average classes these are preparation
for 80cc
as they're both mentally and physically
very very hard and um uh we had many
people come in and try to train
alongside us and they fell
off by the side of the road within Days
forget about weeks months or a full year
of this
um
I gave a very abbreviated set of skills
for the athletes I chopped everything
down to what I believed were the the
most essential skills
um uh anything that wasn't essential to
ADCC preparation was just pushed aside
and
um they had to focus almost entirely on
ADCC with one exception I'll come to
that soon
um of the the period of their training
here in Austin so it was
compacted by time and also by uh the
breadth of skill that I taught
everything was just purely for ADCC
preparation in a very short period of
time uh Dan manisoyo and Luke Griffith
and Oliver Taza all won European trials
and got into ADCC Nicholas murugali was
already a superstar so he was invited
but he had to show himself so we
enrolled him in local
shows here in Austin where he had his
first three uh no game matches
um
and with each match you could see
progress being made and so that
convinced the 80cc people okay he's good
enough to to compete
um he ended up winning decisively a
match against one of the greatest
American Grapplers of all time Raphael
Lovato and this was like a clear sign
that his
skill level and nogi was sufficient to
to justify and invite
and by the way Lovato had an incredible
uh
set of matches in this ADCC yes that was
actually very impressive and retired
yeah
which is a really impressive and
heartbreaking as well but if you go out
that's a good way to go out indeed
so there was this um uh long and tough
preparation and it was compounded by the
fact that it's golden felt better he
felt a need to
build up his own competitive record
prior to ADCC
because he'd been inactive for so long
with his stomach issue so he proposed
one of the most ambitious
fight games that I've ever heard of in
grappling which was he would take on the
current wno champion Pedro Mourinho
who's number one is w owner yeah and
also I believe the current uh no nogi
world champion and IBG if
so tune-up match as a warm-up match then
he would fight his old nemesis
uh Felipe Pena the only man who
submitted Gordon at black dalt and had
defeated Gordon in an 80cc match in
2017.
and then ADCC itself so there was going
to be three big high profile matches
back to back and uh
and very different rule sets so wno was
a 15-minute match uh the fight with
Felipe Pena was no time limit which is a
very different format to compete in and
then ADCC so we had to drag out a
14-week cam covering three matches with
three different rule sets which went and
diametrically opposite directions and
the entire team had to go through all of
this over this 14-week period in
addition to the previous year that they
had been working hard
um there was a further complication in
the midst of all this Nicholas murugali
had to go to the ghee World
Championships and we had to throw an
extra morning class for that to help him
get ready
um Nicholas went on to win the open
weight gold medal in Ziggy competition
and then the next day he had to come
back to Texas and begin his ADCC
preparation it was a crazy crazy time
um but they all came through it so well
I'm I'm immensely proud of what they did
and shockingly in the space of less than
12 months we went from Rock Bottom to
having a more successful ADCC
uh team performance than we did the
previous ADCC
um uh it was in fact the most successful
team performance of the event and as
testimony to how hard those those young
men uh worked in uh in the course of
less than a year to prepare themselves
if we can just Linger on the low point
is it heartbreaking to you that
the so-called Donahue death squad split
or the team as it was originally called
split
you know we live a short life on this
Earth and you put so much of your love
and work into this team and everybody
put in the work does it break your heart
it was a sad time yeah it was
um it was uh
you know I'm not a particularly
emotional person
um but it was a it was an emotional time
for everyone it was I had an element of
tragedy in so far as Not only was it a
team breakup it was also a family
breakup which is much more serious
um I do believe that in time uh
even the most intense family breakups
can be reconciled and I also believe
that once dialogue begins
people will remember
just how easy it was for us to get along
and how tight we were for many many
years
um it's so easy to let
a minute of anger destroy
10 years of of uh of friendship so
but there's also the weight of those 10
years like
um when I ran into the old Squad members
at ADCC we got along like a house on
fire it's like we never had a problem
um so a house on fire is a good thing
yes yes sorry that's a New Zealand
expression yeah
um uh yeah that definitely could have
gone the other way right
um so only in New Zealand I would say
that it's a good thing yeah
um so there's there's I I still believe
you know in in time things will be fine
but
um
there was an element where you know
youngsters need to grow and um uh
sometimes
think think about it this way from The
Athlete's perspective
there's a definitely a generational
problem I'm much older than my students
okay and the the the years and the
Viewpoint that I have is a reflection of
the time in which I grew up
and uh they're from a completely
different generation with a completely
different world view
um it's it's got to be hard from The
Athlete's perspective when you're
training seven days a week and you
you're getting very very good you're
beating everyone that's getting getting
put in front of you and you're losing
very very rarely and it's always a tough
competitive match when you do
everyone around you is calling you a
superstar
and you look phenomenal
you check social media everyone's saying
you're you're a God on the mat
and then you come into the gym there's
some old guy telling you you're not good
enough
and every day it's like oh what does
this guy want from me how how hard do I
have to work like you're not good enough
like I want you to be the best in the
world I want you to be good I want you
to be great
and all your friends are telling you all
day man you're incredible you submit me
so easily do this to you and then this
old guys are saying that
you got to get better you got to work
more you're not working hard enough
at some point you're going to be like
you know what [ __ ] this old guy
like it's it's tough you know mentally I
I get my you know they lasted when I was
20 years old I didn't get along with
authority figures at all and um uh to
have someone telling you you've always
got to work that little bit harder
though your skill set's not complete you
still need this this and this when
you're already
doing very very well and far better than
all what a tiny tiny percentage of
people and then you've got this guy just
constantly telling you no more has to be
done you're not there yet
um I can you know of course I understand
you just when let me just enjoy this
more like it's always a choice in life
do you you can be the best you possibly
can or you can
go around where you just get to enjoy
life a little more you do other things
you know like there's more of a to life
than just the inside of a gym and
learning how to do a better heel hook or
a better double leg
um so of course you know years go by you
want to try other things and
um uh you have to make this choice in
life between
extreme Excellence versus being
incredibly good but maybe just enjoying
my life a little more it's so
interesting that incredibly good is a
hard thing to deal with I saw like when
Kayla Harrison won her first gold medal
and uh the Olympics
you know to go back to the gym and to
trust again the maybe the old man you're
you're being do washing yourself but to
trust the old man so Jimmy pager on
Jimmy pager senior in that case to say
okay we're gonna go back to this grind
and there's still a path to Improvement
there's still a lot to grow and still
have the humility even though you've
just demonstrated greatness so really
good is just a stepping stone to to to
to Greatness that's really tough for
athletes like winning is actually very
difficult gold medals are very difficult
plus there's the personal stuff of
depression that comes with that which is
you give so much of yourself to trying
to win that and once you do
there's a lot of personal stuff you have
to deal with which is like
what what uh what do I want from life
to understand what is exactly what am I
chasing is it just winning or is it some
bigger picture of Excellence that's
beyond just winning so that that's all
all that mixed up together and then when
you have to be as a team really close
together there's the personal
relationships all that gets exacerbated
yeah do you think the team ever gets
back together
I think there's all you know there's
definitely a chance of that right now I
think they have a an excellent team
themselves and they're doing very well
uh they had an excellent performance at
ADCC so there's not a need for them to
uh to come to us because they're like
they lack anything they still remember
everything I taught them they still
coach and teach with the same
methodology that I told them so um I
don't think they have any need to do so
uh if they did it would be because they
wanted to
um I still think many of the same
personality conflicts that originated
the conflict would re-emerge currently
if if they started training together uh
by the way to pile on the compliments
they have really nice merch to the
t-shirts are just excellent
um
what have you learned from that process
about how to have a team with personal
conflicts do you have to deal with these
giant egos as well yeah because ego is
in part of superpower too so you don't
want to yeah you you don't want to
suppress EOS I I always laugh when
people say leave your ego at the door
it's like what do you think drives
competition like if you want to be good
at anything in life you've got to have
an ego
um
uh no I don't believe it's good or even
a healthy thing to suppress he goes um
I'm a realist and I understand that this
is a sport where they make one gold
medal per weight division this as guys
get better they're going to be looking
at their training partners and thinking
like
I'm gonna have to fight this guy one day
and they're training next to each other
of course it's going to be tension
um there's always going to be uh
disagreements about you know what's the
right way to act around uh certain
people certain issues and people are
going to come into conflict everyone's
being programmed to be a an alpha
competitor and you get a room full of P
like that there's going to be conflict
now your question was well is there a
way to resolve this yeah there was and
for
eight to nine years I was very
successful with this but there's also a
Tipping Point where things can flare out
of control and there will be periodic
breakups you know they're not the first
students I had that that left I've been
coaching a lot longer they've been
coaching the squad and
um uh
I'm sure in the future there'll be other
students who leave me hey that's just
the nature of the Beast it's sad when it
happens but Life Goes On
uh like Bukowski said love is a fog that
Fades with the first uh daylight of
reality or something like that so you
even love is temporary uh
let me ask you about leading up the the
preparation
for the athletes I mean this is such
given the darkness from from a year ago
from which you had to find glimmers of
light and try to get greatness out of
athletes what was the mental preparation
like
for Gordon for Nicholas
uh for Giancarlo for the other athletes
what was the mental side of things like
is there some key insights you can give
to their mental preparation I really
think that people when they talk about
mental preparation need to take a step
back and realize that almost every
element of what people describe as
mental preparation his physical
underpinnings
um
literally 95 of what I teach the
athletes is physical skills
and it's my belief that every mental
aspect of competition
the most important which will be
confidence on stage is a direct result
of the the accumulation of physical
skills
people tend to see things like
confidence as a mental state
it is but it comes out of
the performance of physical skills
all my life I've seen Sports
psychologists try to
create confidence in athletes through
non-physical means
and it always ends up being the same
kind of cheesy motivational speeches
um highlight video reels where they try
to pump
artificial confidence into people
and
I've never been impressed by this nor
have I you know have any kind of
positive effect on on Athlete
Performance
what I do see build confidence is the
sense that athletes are developing
skills and using them successfully under
conditions that closely mirror the event
they're preparing for
once they get this down that's where
true confidence comes from confidence
doesn't come from words it comes from
accumulated skills which experience
shows you have
been responsible for successful
performances in the past and if you
accumulate enough of these your
confidence Rises
so
when it comes to the mental aspects of
competition I created a program where
everyone had us was given a set of
skills that they had to work on skills
directly related to what I believe is
the most important elements of success
in ADCC competition
in the gym they accumulated those skills
over time I do it in two different ways
depending on whether these are offensive
skills or defensive skills
for the accumulation of offensive skills
I like to have my athletes work with
athletes who are lesser than themselves
in ability
so that they start to
gain confidence over time just as you
would never send a beginner into a
weightlifting German put 500 pounds on
the bar and tell them to lift it rather
you would start with
a wooden bar then the metal bar and then
gradually accumulate weight over time so
you get a progression in weightlifting
so too and juditsu you don't take a
brand new move and say okay do it on
Gordon Ryan
never going to succeed
uh I have the athletes practice their
offense on Blue belts and work their way
up
defense on the other hand you've got to
start them in the deep end of the pool
so that they start to see what are their
vulnerabilities okay so I put them with
highly competitive athletes at this
start so they can see okay there is a
problem here and then even in defense
they start off with lower belts and
build up their confidence over time
so just as a weightlifter builds up his
ability to build weight sorry to lift
weight over time so to a Jujitsu player
does it by gradually increasing
resistance now in Jiu Jitsu resistance
is not done by weight it's done by skill
level and so over time they started to
accumulate this experience
in time
um they uh we were able to switch off
and have them go against
very very tough athletes each other so
you know uh Luke Griffiths will do a
full power match with Gordon Ryan now
they're fully aware that there's no one
better in the world than Gordon Ryan so
if you have a competitive match with
Gordon Ryan that's a very very healthy
sign so they went from the start where
they were being programmed going against
relatively mild resistance and building
up over time and then building up to the
greatest resistance possible in the
sport of jiu jitsu
and their goal is not to win obviously
but their goal is to provide a
competitive match
now Gordon doesn't have any confidence
issues so for him it's just good hard
competitive training against people that
are
in some ways better than those you'll be
facing in competition for the other guys
it's
getting a clear assessment of what their
current skill level is
by going against the best there is
then we add to this a competitive
schedule where the athletes have to go
out into competition so they get used to
the idea of performing in front of
strangers
on stage getting used to the the strange
elements of going out being observed and
judged by people you don't know in a
performance atmosphere and so they were
all given matches and wno competition
leading up to the event uh ADCC trials
local grappling events here in Austin
and given a competitive schedule to
fight and prepare them for ADCC
obviously as ADCC got closer and closer
this was pulled back because of the
danger of injury So within about three
weeks out was the last time we had a
competition
and by this method confidence starts to
grow and uh and so the mental
preparation came out of those physical
underpaints the idea of progressive
resistance increasing over time uh for
both offense and defense building up to
a peak where they go in against the best
athlete in the world so they can get an
accurate assessment of where they stand
once you're given a competitive match to
the best guy in the world you know damn
well that when you go out in 80cc you're
ready to fight anybody
and defense is broadly defined so
defense and
in symmetrical positions like positions
like guard and then defense also
includes escaping from horrible
positions yes
um we're big Believers in the idea of
depth of Defense the idea that uh you
should be able to mount defense all the
way through from early stages based
mostly around anticipation of
identifying danger visually before it
emerges and all the way through to the
deepest levels of Defense where you are
100 defensive and terrible positions and
you have to claw your way out and uh
over time and get back to a neutral
position or even better back to an
attacking position you have an Instagram
post on this topic
um when you get ready to step out for
the biggest moment of your life ask
yourself one question how different is
this really from what I do every day if
the answer is not very different at all
then step forward with confidence and do
we do every day in the same manner and
ignore the hype and distraction you're
ready for action by the way for people
who don't know you need to follow John
Donahue or Donahue John on Instagram
because uh you have nuggets or large
buckets of nuggets of wisdom often which
is quite profound even bigger than Jiu
Jitsu but anyway so there's some aspect
where you want to mimic the conditions
of your daily training
in um intensity and
in what fossil physical
uh to that of the actual yeah uh
mattress you asked the question about
mental training for me
um the central focus of whatever small
amount of mental training I give my
students comes down to a very very
simple concept to understand this is the
idea of
identifying competition in terms of its
normalcy
most people see training and competition
is two different things training is
normal activity that you do every day
and competition is the exception okay
it's different you're going out there's
people watching you there's a big crowd
they're making lots of noise
um
in fact
the promoters of shows go out of their
way to reinforce this look at for
example ADCC when Gordon Ryan went to
fight Andre Galvan okay do they just
come out on the mat and fight each other
absolutely not this music there's a
pageantry there's Fireballs they're
literally shooting Fireballs yeah some
dude in a tie sitting with Joe Rogan I
heard about that meat head uh podcast or
comedian whatever uh which one was the
meat hit
what well played John Idaho well played
but you see what they're trying to do
they're trying to create theater and
pageantry when in fact it's just a
grappling match it's just two athletes a
referee and a rule set that's that's the
reality
now what they try to sell you is
something which is not reality which is
this is somehow bigger and different
and they reinforce this with pageantry
and theater so that it becomes not just
a grappling match but a grappling
performance the same way you have a
theater performance
and my goal as a coach is to dispel that
and say when you go out there
there's only one reality
you him and the referee reinforcing a
rules there that's it
everything else you see the smoke the
fire the music is an illusion
and it's put there intentionally to make
you feel a certain kind of way and your
whole goal is to see this as an illusion
and walk out and see only the reality
which is that this is the same damn
thing you do every day in the gym
the only difference is you're going with
a guy you've never grappled before
so the actual act of removing the
illusion or realizing that it is an
illusion
how do you practice that so when you
step on the mat once you're aware of it
I I always have them to you it it it's
like when you when you see a magician
and you have his tricks explained to you
you never see the magic again the first
time you see a good card trick from a
good magician's oh my God then when they
explain it to you I did this this and
that step one step two
then you look at it like it's not that
special
and when you explain to people this idea
is the pageantry is an illusion
then just as when you watch the magician
and you learn the trick
all the magic flies out the window so
too with the the nervous response so
that's for the pageantry but what about
the maybe the physical intensity of
competition isn't there
an extra no it's the same in every
competition this it's not like you know
they're twice as strong and 80cc is
there and the ibjf World Championships
it's the physical intensity is always
pretty much the same they experience it
every day in the gym and
um uh like you know if you go out and
you grapple Gordon Ryan it's not like
the next guy who grapple is going to be
twice as strong as hell or twice as fast
this could be a little stronger a little
faster but not so much so that it
completely changes your approach of the
game
um you know there's not that much
difference between the human bodies out
there on stage so if you've felt
intensity before you're not going to be
shocked by ADCC but in terms of in
training
do you have to try to match the
intensity of competition no
um that would be fool should be every
athlete in the gym would be injured uh
you can do it for short periods of time
um but the uh the training has to be
carefully monitored in terms of
intensity levels remember we're training
seven days a week a minimum of twice a
day
um you you've got to keep things under
wraps like you know every other workout
you can have a like one of the five
rounds can be full power but not seven
days a week three times a day that's
that's just gonna break bodies and the
full power is just a reminder
of it's more about skill development for
us it always comes back to school
development but what about matching the
the feeling of the intensity of
competition
so yeah periodically periodically it
can't be rare a single time not not
really it's not rare like yeah meaning
like you know one like out of you know
three hours of hot sparring per day like
15 minutes might be like 100 full power
that way you you that's more than enough
to get psychologically ready for the
intensity of conflict but um uh but
won't break your body over time
intensity of conflict that's well put
there is uh competition does doesn't it
have that extra level of animosity
okay it's a little bit more conflict
than it is it can sometimes these
personality differences like for example
like Gordon Ryan and Felipe Pena they
admire each other a lot they respect
each other's skills but they they
certainly don't like love each other
that's for sure so um uh so there can be
certain match up with this more
intensity
um but then there's other matchups where
the two athletes come out and it's
um it's no more intense than a hard
sparring session
so first of all because I would love to
look at a couple of matches with you and
uh before that let me say big thank you
to flow grappling uh for first of all
helping the sport of grappling and Jiu
Jitsu in general by having organized
footage
and uh tournaments that sort of show the
sport in its best light to the world and
they do an incredible job of that so if
you're interested in supporting
grappling as a sport helping you grow
you should definitely support flow
grappling go to their website sign out
also flow wrestling I'm a huge fan of
wrestling so
um maybe there'll be a flow Judo at some
point they don't currently I don't think
do any major Judo stuff so anyway I I'm
a big supporter of theirs and I do have
criticism
that they know about which is uh I hope
they continue to improve on the aspect
of making the footage discoverable and
accessible making it easy for you to do
search through Google and on their
website to find matches to get excited
like if me and Joe Rogan are getting
excited about a particular match we want
to be able to pull it up super quickly
want to be able to pull up Gordon Ryan's
matches super quickly from ADCC make it
super easy to show and share if we have
to pay for it fine but make it easy and
when you sign you know to sign up for
flow it should be one click not five
clicks it should be one click it should
be easy
I think it's inexpensive if you care
about grappling it's definitely worth it
you should sign up anyway my love goes
out to flow grappling and also my love
goes out to mojasum as we said uh he's
the organizer of ADCC the next one is in
2024. it should be 2024 well you should
follow ADCC the underscore official on
Instagram and just send as much love
towards Mo and ADCC in general it's the
like I said the the most prestigious
it's like we're the best grapples in the
world show up and the magic happens it's
like some of the most historic matches
in uh grappling Jiu Jitsu ever happened
on that stage uh anyway if I can talk
about some of the interesting
performances for the athletes you coach
you post on Instagram let's start with
Gordon Ryan Gordon Ryan ADCC 2022 the
greatest event in grappling history is
over new stars emerged established Stars
shown bright again but one man stood
above all like a Colossus Gordon Ryan
you have a way with words John Donner uh
I have seen many incredible Feats of
grappling but have never saw a
performance like this for many Mr Ryan
is a polarizing figure in the sport for
many others and inspiration to look up
to but after this weekend there was no
disagreement amongst haters and fans
about his Merit he is the best ever
it was a long and difficult journey to
ADCC 2022 just one year ago and so on as
you told the story
it was a virtuoso performance of
unmatched technique preparation and
confidence no one else can claim credit
for this achievement this was his and
his alone no one else today brings
together technical depth tactical
insight and confidence to use them on
stage as he does I had many students but
only one Gordon Ryan and I think Gordon
responded all this is true besides the
credit that sits with you thank you and
a heart emoji very nice so anyway that's
as a way of introduction to Gordon Ryan
can you take me through his set of
performances it may be any matches that
stand out
so he competed in his division which is
the plus 99 kilos and in the super fight
against Andre gova that's correct uh
this was in fact the first time in in
history that this was uh allowed
um for your uh listeners who don't
follow grappling
um we may have been very rude and just
throwing a lot of stuff at you without
explaining ourselves first of all ADCC
is like the Olympics of grappling uh it
occurs every two years
um you can either qualify for the event
through uh winning matches and a
qualification process or you can be
invited the only people who get invited
are either former winners or people on
the sport who are just widely recognized
superstars who bring some kind of brand
value who have proven in the past that
they have what it takes to compete at
that level
in this format there are two kinds of
matches
there are
weight division matches
in which you compete against people your
own uh roughly your own size and weight
there is an open weight where anyone of
any size can enter so you can have very
small people fighting very large people
and there is a second category called a
super fight where established Champions
who have won previous open weight uh uh
tournaments
fight each other in one-off battles one
athlete against another so in most of
the uh matches you will you will fight
repetitively over time towards a gold
medal but in one category you fight one
fight the so-called super fight which is
usually the headline fight of the event
um traditionally if you were in the
Super fight you could not compete in the
weight categories
it was seen as too risky because you
might get injured
during the weight category or you might
have to fight four very tough fights in
a row and get exhausted so that you're
ineffective during the main event of the
uh of the show the super fight
so throughout its history ADCC has
always resisted the idea of an athlete
being allowed to do both weight category
and uh super fight it's never happened
before
Gordon Ryan requested to be able to do
this
um because of his extraordinary stature
in the sport
the ADCC organization granted his
request that was the first time ever
in addition Gordon Ryan would be
fighting to be the first person to win
three gold medals in three different
weight categories this has never been
done before
so it was a huge event on Gordon's part
and bear in mind also that prior to this
event he had fought
just a month and a half earlier against
a former ADCC open weight champion
Felipe Pena who had defeated him in the
past and a completely different rule set
and then previously that against the
current world champion so there had been
a build up to this so he had been very
active
uh uh coming up to the event and then he
went in to fight arguably the greatest
ACC champion of all time Andre Galvan
which would occurred late on Sunday and
would have to fight
the toughest people including uh the
possibility of fighting his Nemesis
Felipe Pena in the weight division prior
to getting to the Super fight so there
was genuine concern here that he may
have completely overstepped himself
um the biggest concern I had as a coach
and I'm sure the organizers Mo Jessica
must have had the same concern so he
would get injured or exhausted fighting
in his weight division
there were two athletes in particular uh
Felipe Pena who had given Gordon a very
tough 40-minute match and a no rules
setting
um uh shortly before ADCC and his former
training partner uh Nick Rodriguez
um who were expected to give Gordon very
very tough matches if they came up
against each other
so
there was a genuine concern that Gordon
may burn himself out before he even got
to fight the guy who most people believe
was the greatest ADCC champion of all
time
so our concern was how do we manage this
so what we looked for is extremely
efficient methods of reducing the time
of the measures making the matches as
short as possible
um our favorite way to fight bigger
stronger athletes and I think Gordon was
the lightest athlete in his weight
division everyone goes all going so big
and strong which is actually quite light
um uh I think it was outweighed by
almost all of his opponents
it's nice to see Gordon looking small
relative to his opponents which is
absurd to say but it is the open
division plus 99 kilos it was plus 99
kilos right that's what I mean sorry by
open plus 99 kilos everyone looks like
the Incredible Hulk yeah yeah so
um our big thing is when we fight bigger
stronger opponents we always go in two
directions you either go for the legs or
you go for the back and so
um we constructed strategies based
around those two methods so going for
submissions and we should also mention
that agcc rule said is for regular
matches I think it's five minutes and
five minutes total is 10 minutes and
then for finals matches it's 20 minutes
and half the time is spent with no
points
so these can be very very long matches
let me put this in a perspective a
modern Judo matches five minutes and
modern wrestling match I believe is six
minutes in international freestyle
um so these matches can be 40 minutes
long now that's a long long grappling
match yeah and um depending on how you
compete in it that can have a huge tour
absolutely you can get to the finals and
just be absolutely spent so our whole
thing is okay Gordon's got to not only
get to the finals then he's got to fight
the toughest 80cc rapper of all time
after that so um we were looking for
quick and energy efficient matches and
that meant going to the back or going to
the legs
um and in the overwhelming majority of
cases that's exactly what he did he was
able to get some very very quick matches
uh courtesy of leglock finishes and in
the few cases where he didn't finish on
legs then he would simply take his
opponents back and uh that's a very low
stress position to to occupy in one case
uh his opponent deliberately kept his
back on the ground to prevent the back
tag and he just chose mounted position
instead and so he was able to go through
his weight division with extremely low
energy expenditure which set him up well
to go into the uh the finals no injuries
very little energy expenditure now it
sounds easy to say that you know oh okay
the strategy worked
but in order to get that strategy to
work you have to have one hell of a set
of skills and
um uh and we can see those now would you
like to yeah I would love to go through
them and I should also mention for
people just listening to this we'll I'll
try to commentate on different things
we'll look at but
the thing that was made clear is uh
maybe you can
speak to that
maybe to you it looks like efficiency
but to me it looked like
a Gordon was not even trying there's a
um a relaxed aspect to the whole thing
so maybe it had to do with saving energy
but he made it look very easy yeah and
he made the the pathos submission look
very easy so here the first match
against an opponent that again looks
bigger than him
okay I'll just give an initial comment
here
um first you'll see that Gordon elected
to sit to the bottom position
um the hardest work in submission
grappling is when two athletes take the
standing position and just for takedowns
uh that's where most of the energy gets
burned up so working on the idea of
Energy Efficiency let's go out and we we
chose to sit into guard position and
then start looking to access our
opponents back because if our opponent's
hit position a far side arm drag makes a
lot of sense Gordon's able to beat the
arm and quickly get behind his opponent
now the question is going to be getting
into a scoring position it's too early
to score at this point but we're just
concerned at this stage of just energy
expenditure and make the other guy work
harder than us so uh going to the arm
drag to the back and I was working on
the hooks
um the hooks are not particularly
important here he'll use it just to get
stability on his opponent but um
interestingly his opponent here had an
interesting strategy too which was to
occupy bottom Turtle position and uh and
look to get to the critical five-point
Demarcus sorry our five minute
demarcation point where points began
begin to get scored his idea I believe
I'm speculating here based on his
actions was to keep Gordon at Bay in a
defensive Turtle position until a five
minute Mark occurred in which case he
would Shake Gordon off walk away and
force a takedown battle how many people
are are comfortable in that and what do
you think about the defense attorney
position versus always trying to come
back to guard the total position is the
second bottom position of units so many
people only associate God position with
bottom position and Jiu-Jitsu that's
that's naive there's two there's guard
position and turtle position now as a
general rule guard position offers a
much much greater variety of attacking
options then total position does
but that's not to say turtle position
absolutely Can Be
an Effective bottom position you can
work effectively from there so there's
some case to be made that to wait out
five minutes the turtle might be I mean
I I personally think it it get against
Gordon Ryan I mean I admire the fellows
courage I I
um it's not easy but there was a logic
to what he was doing uh people think oh
he just got his back taken so easily but
he did have a strategy now did he pick
the right person to use that strategy
against probably not
um so Gordon is able to uh break the
turtle down get one hook in
at which point I I is this becoming an
uh extremely controlling position with
Gordon in the back at which point is
there are you happy with where at this
point uh it just started to dawn on me
at this point this guy actually had a
strategy which was to maintain a a prone
position that he's in now and then Shake
golden off after the five minute Mark so
um uh once that became obvious then I
was uh now decided to look at the clock
and how close we are if you can take it
up to five minutes
right now this guy's only intention is
to stop going from strangling him and
finish
okay now the guy's trying to go up and
vertical uh freeze it there now do you
see how he's taking his elbows off the
mat and turtle position in Jiu Jitsu
there's only one reason you take your
elbows off the mat from Turtle position
it's to stand up so now it's it's clear
at this point what his actual strategy
is it's to get up for sustaining
confrontation when a takedown battle and
be Gordon by points so he did have a
strategy now our counter strategy is
always based around the power half
Nelson this is a common move in the
sport of wrestling and it's a great way
to break people down as they try to
stand up so heavy yeah I mean Gordon is
a master of it and so there's a power
Nelson that Gordon has on him as the as
the elbows are off the ground and knees
are off the ground he's going to return
his opponent to the mat and as you can
see he's successful in doing so and now
it's clear what demand strategy is so
I'm calling to Gordon to break him down
to a hip you put a man on a hip you
can't stand up Gordon successfully does
it traps the shoulder using that
one-on-one grip with his right hand puts
him down to a shoulder and a half that
means standing up is no longer an option
for his opponent now Gordon goes in he's
already scoring because of the uh the
total position that he's in his
shoulders his opponent stays down on his
shoulder now Gordon's responsibility to
start looking for the Stranglehold his
opponent has basic defensive structures
disciplined with his chin keeps the chin
down but Gordon is a master of tying up
defensive arms and penetrating under the
chin to get to a strangle you'll see
that shortly
is the trapping of the arm
notice that no Advanced uh
uh groups were required it was just a
spontaneous trap just the penetration of
the neck
so the arm was trapped with the leg Yeah
so now he's only got one defensive arm
and he's just taking that away with his
left hand he gets a one-handed strangle
for the Finish
and it looks like not much energy was
expanded during very little yeah so
that's a as the tournament got off to a
very smooth start very lingy expenditure
no injuries and a submission win
does that
there's a kind of certain look to Gordon
of that could be interpreted as
nervousness that was an incorrect
interpretation yes okay so there's a uh
what do you interpret as nervous
Behavior
well this is uh part of me is trolling
but
sometimes on the surface confident
Behavior can look like uh
almost like anger
and there's a
Gordon's face had a like a vulnerability
to it
almost like uh when you go to judge
confidence don't look at the face look
at the extremities of the body yeah
that's where the truth comes out you see
it in body language and the further from
the face and cheers the more honest the
body becomes
look at the feet and the hands
well there were I mean that's when you
see if people are nervous or not he was
very relaxed uh in the extremities
that's true see you look more confident
in this in this than anything what what
are you thinking about what I what uh
what's going through your head here
all right this is the same stuff are you
are you intimidated by the the two Meat
Heads one in a suit and tie or are you
not thinking about that at all I know
now for me it's just about okay what's
the most efficient positive Victory
against this particular opponent it's
just okay I've done my job I've taken
him through a uh an extensive fight camp
that prepared them for every conceivable
situation that they're in uh I've run an
efficient warm-up their body temperature
is perfect the elasticity in the muscles
is perfect
um
my main role when I corner
is I avoid what most people do when they
Corner which is to be a cheerleader most
cornermen they're not cornermen they're
cheerleaders they're there to express
some kind of emotional support to their
training partners and or their their
student sometimes they're even worse
than cheerleaders they express their own
emotional fears
as the match goes on
um
I always believe that 99.5 percent of
the job of the trainer is done the coach
is done
when the athlete steps their foot on the
mat
at that point
you shouldn't need me at all everything
I needed to tell you should have been
not just told you but imprinted into you
remember this fifteen thousand people in
that crowd for half of the match you're
not going to hear a word that I can say
there's too much noise but you'll hear
my voice inside your head
because you've heard it so many times
over the last 14 weeks you're sick of
hearing it at that point
in their program know what to do
um so I'm I'm usually
pretty confident I'm also very confident
that even in worst case scenarios
they're going to have effective
Solutions because they train those worst
case scenarios every single day in the
gym
and so in part you're there to have a
front row seat
to analyze what happened so you can take
that to the next match the biggest
danger an athlete faces is tunnel vision
sometimes they will
Hit Upon A Certain move or strategy and
just say I'm going to go with this when
there's much easier Alternatives but
because they're so focused on the
alternative they've chosen they get this
tunnel vision and just focus only on
that the most constructive thing the
corner man can do is alert them to the
presence of time which is very important
in ADCC match because they're all the
scoring is structured by time and to
alleviate problems associated with
tunnel vision that okay you're doing
this
but if you just did this it'll be so
much easier so that's the main goal so
here uh this was one of several
anticipated matches against a second one
against Victor Hugo
which is a very tough opponent
and uh again this was a situation where
golden was considerably outweighed by
his opponent so the main thing here was
efficiency his opponent elected to avoid
the standing position by jumping into
God so now guard yeah yeah golden would
be in top position this time he has a
very good closed guard but unfortunately
Gordon has very good God passing so um
uh he he's an excellent guard player
very talented but Gordon is renowned as
the imminent God Pastor in the world
today so
um it's a tall order to hold Gordon off
for a 10-minute match is there something
you can say about this guard passing
Gordon is making it look very easy it's
middle distance guard passing here
um and he eventually passes to mount I
believe
in a very uh again why don't you run
through the sequence where he gets
mounted this uh there's a couple I
believe he gets mounted twice as I'm not
I just back just a little bit further
yeah
so he's trying to one one arm under yeah
this is a stacking position now normally
we always insist on the idea of getting
advantageous angle first controlling the
feet and getting angle
um but there's a height advantage that
Victor Hugo has here and the length of
his legs
um means that he can play very very wide
with his leg so getting an advantageous
angle might be difficult in these
circumstances it often makes sense to go
right up the middle
um now Gordon could just go back for
legs because the legs Victor Hugo's legs
are so far apart at this point that you
could easily isolate a leg and attack
there but Gordon wanted to uh to show
off his passing prowess very often he'll
go into a match and say okay I'm gonna
I'm gonna show this skill and he'll
often use it as a demonstration of um
techniques he teaches in instructional
videos so he wanted to show that he
could pass them out readily on a world
champion like this part here
this little step okay I just freeze it
right there go back one step okay you
can clearly see that all of his
opponents defensive frames are built on
his opponent's left hand side so
everything is defense on the on the left
but you can see this comes at a price
and that price is back exposure on the
right hand side you can literally see
his opponents back on that side so
Gordon's whole uh game is to to place
sufficient pressure that you the
opponent overcompensates on the side of
pressure just to set up a quick switch
across to the other side there's the
vulnerability
there's the back exposure his opponent
has to put his back on the ground
switches back that's a world champion
right there on bottom who does a good
job of recovering from the first danger
but unfortunately Gordon has been here a
thousand times and kicks out a little
little step and so you see there's two
changes in Direction left right in a
very short period of time that people
find very very hard to keep up with now
his opponent builds up to an album he's
looking to to create more and more space
from here but Gordon count is by just
stepping over the hips it's just when
and you you feel like every move he's
doing the right things the man on bottom
is doing well he's doing the right
things but the other guys just been here
too many times and it's just a half
second ahead of every decision going up
in the elbow
and Gordon makes it look so easy here
with the it's it almost seems like uh
Victor's out
but this turning of the hips with the
arm over the opponent's back he's able
to bring him back down and get and
Gordon takes mount
notice how golden is never satisfied
with the mounted position itself he's
only satisfied with an extended mounted
position with the elbow comes up over
the shoulder line
he only then does he show there's a
there's a little bit of relief right
there right right
there's a little bit of relief now
that's that's the look of a man who's
just proved a point
oh yeah this is very Michael Jordan like
sticks his tongue out so yeah I mean
there's no points at the stage he really
is going for submission
and then this this happens again
is this the match that wasn't Gordon was
the only match where Gordon didn't uh
finish his opponent by submission
was just very frustrating for him was
there uh it's actually interesting that
when he came off the mat
um uh he was visibly frustrated he
wanted to uh to get a finish and
um I think he was more upset about not
finishing Victor Hugo then he was
delighted by winning his two gold medals
um
uh so I think that says a lot about the
perfectionism of Gordon Ryan most people
would be thrilled to beat one of the
great Grapplers of this generation
decisively in this fashion but he was uh
he was not happy
and so this is a Gordon's third match
against uh Souza Roosevelt Souza now
there's another guy who's yeah very big
uh different because now we're on to the
second day
um your listeners should be aware that
the event occurs over a two-day period
so the previous two matches occurred on
Saturday now we're into Sunday now this
puts a different context on things if we
could just freeze it right there maybe
go back one step
um now we're on Sunday morning and the
idea is that Gordon will be fighting the
biggest fight of his life late that
afternoon so now we're into the idea of
energy conservation okay it's okay to
have two hard matches on on Saturday
because you get to rest on Saturday
night but now Gordon has to beat two
people
back to back and save energy for the
biggest fight of his life on Sunday uh
late Sunday afternoon so now the
emphasis is on a quick win and you can
see Gordon Ryan
certainly delivers on this now when you
go to entangle your opponent's legs the
basic choice you have is between
straight ashigurami and cross ashigurami
um
in the last five years cross ashigrami
has proven to be statistically the more
important of the two
um and as a result many people have
forgotten the value of straight
ashigurami leg base leg locks and
undervalued them Gordon has outstanding
heel hooks from both straight and cross
positions and his opponent was probably
more concerned about the danger of a
cross ashigurami left the the right leg
uh undefended for far too long and as a
result Gordon goes into
a very classical
ashigrama you would normally expect to
see from five or six years ago and gets
a very very quick finish so lifts his
opponent
there's the ashigurami the entanglement
of one of his opponent's legs were two
of his now he's got to turn and expose
his opponent's heel so there's an
initial off balance to the left to get a
defensive reaction the opponent
overcompensates exposes his heel and
then there's the submission
leg being broken here Gordon has a
absolutely ferocious uh outside here
okay until you felt it it's um it's
quite different so the the opponent
probably before he even felt the heel
hook felt the control that it's yeah
it's I think he's screwed there yeah he
doesn't even want the yeah when someone
has a someone who knows what they're
doing gets a bite on your leg like that
you feel it deep inside your knee and
Ankle tendons immediately and um
it's there's a sense in which you almost
tap
uh he got a couple of TAPS almost almost
like as if they're early because people
came out to us and said this guy tapped
early he's like no he knew yeah yeah he
knew that uh late would be a big problem
got it so this is within within within
like 30 seconds within 10 seconds he was
within 10 seconds so this was a
excellent example of someone saying Okay
I'm going to conserve energy with a
short match I'm not just going to go
down into a neutral position I'm going
to directly pull into a leg lock attack
from standing position you don't see
that much in heavyweight divisions
that's something you see more in the
lightweight divisions
so we got to go to the final match of uh
of Gordon's within his division which I
think
um as opposed to uh facing Philippe Pena
who lost to Nikki Rod he's Nikki Road
had a great match against Felipe panett
um uh and uh past Felipe panna's God I
think only the second person in 80cc
competition to accomplish that I believe
with the with the body luck uh it
started as a body lock but he converted
to half guard top head numb and uh
passed out of half guard top chest to
chest I think I listened to uh uh Craig
Jones sort of interview summarizing what
happened agcc and he briefly mentioned
that uh Nikki Rob might have
the best body lock capacity he's ever
felt so like they're very very good with
the ball the way to face I think you're
right is don't get him don't let him get
the body lock but there's any problem if
you stand up he's a good wrestler so he
is there's a dilemma that like you have
to sit down to God but that goes into
his body lock but then if you stand up
now you go into his wrestling skill so
it's it's a great dilemma that he has
and that that's what uh
in in facing and facing uh Nikki Rod
going run here chooses to
foreign
yeah if if you look at the limbs there's
a relaxation there we should also
explain some things here uh this is a
finals match so instead of being 10
minutes long it's 20 minutes long with
the option of a 20 minute overtime so
this could potentially be a 40-minute
match so you can see why the ADCC people
were very concerned about Gordon doing
this match because what if what if this
match had gone 40 minutes and then an
exhaustive Gordon Ryan has to go out to
fight Andre Galvan who's fresh and and
ready to Maul them and then top of that
is former two former teammates who know
each other's game very well so there was
a high likelihood of most people's minds
that this would go the distance because
you know when you train with each other
for years every single day in the gym
seven days a week you you get to know
each other's tricks
um one big problem here for Nikki Rod is
that uh his body lot guard passing game
which is his main way from the ground
was taught to him by us so it's not like
we're going to be taken by surprise by
it so that that must have been figuring
in his mind do you think uh
psychologically for Gordon and
psychologically for Nick Iran it's tough
so for him with that body lock for
example do you think it's tough for him
to know what to do here uh it's tough
because he would have remembered the
outcome of the training sessions it's
hard to go up against a guy who
used to dominate you on training and
then say okay I'm going to beat him in
competition again you shut all that off
because it's tough man memory is memory
you can't lie to yourself you know what
do you think about competition instead
of there there's been a lot of Olympics
bring this out there's been a lot of big
upsets at the Olympics there's something
where people find something in them I
mean Judo
is it is a different sport than
grappling in Judo there's much more room
for upset because a mistake in Judo
will have ramifications that will be
felt within half a second like if you if
you take the wrong grip and Judo you can
be thrown in half a second and there's
no recovery if your two Shoulders hit
the map the momentum it's over it's done
um
in Jiu Jitsu you could especially in
ADCC where there's no points in the
first five minutes you could get taken
down and mounted by your opponent and
still win like you can recover from a
bad start in Judo boxing kickboxing
MMA you get hit there's no recovery time
you just get swarmed on and um Jiu Jitsu
is a much more forgiving sport where you
can make a series of blunders and you
just recover from them you don't make a
series of blunders and boxing you're
unconscious so that there's the blunder
case but there's also been just people
where it's their day
I mean again maybe it's romanticized in
the notion but there's been some epic
performances in Russ in Olympic
wrestling in Olympic Judo as an example
satoshiishi he had a 2008 performance we
talked about all Japan and all that kind
of stuff but the Olympics he destroyed
uh everybody on this path to the Olympic
gold medal and that's when Teddy Romero
was also competing he got the bronze so
I mean that
now you could say he was at that time
the best in the world also but he I mean
yeah but I think it would be very fair
to say he was the best in the world I he
think about the people he beat to win
three old Japan championships like he
beat kosai in a way uh he beat kg Suzuki
they were Olympic Champions like he was
already so you don't believe him he will
I don't believe that a person can walk
on stage and be better than what day is
supposed to be you you have a skill
level it's set in stone this is your
skill level you don't just go on stage
and suddenly your school level gets here
what you do have is a situation where
you have a skill level okay
another opponent has a higher skill
level but he runs into confidence issues
so that he only uses a small percentage
of his actual skills and then he will
fall below someone who is technically
lower on the skill scale than he is that
can happen
but you can't just magically acquire
skills yeah but they're able to fall in
confidence yes so the question becomes
who manages that for best and that can
create upsets absolutely so you don't
think Gordon could have fallen in
confidence against the former teammate
when the pressure is so high there was
just no basis for a fall to occur you
said he doesn't have confidence issues
is uh what do you attribute that to
that's because he never loses in the gym
I mean there's there's nothing in the
there's no experience that he's had that
would make him say I shouldn't be this
confident so it's the physical uh it's
like uh like we talked about mental
preparation but don't get me wrong if
Gordon lost 20 matches in a row of
course his confidence would drop because
experience is now
there's going to be a psychological uh
dissonance between
uh his experience his recent experience
and what he believes okay if you believe
you're best in the world you just lost
20 matches at some point reality is
going to break in but if you're just
never losing in competition
dominating people in the gym
then there's nothing in your experience
that would shake your confidence can I
ask you this just in a small tangent why
is Gordon Ryan so good so we're looking
at you've trained a lot of special
athletes you're a special human being
yourself
I could just look at human history
there's a lot of
not a lot there's some special humans it
seems like Gordon Ryan is one of them I
I totally agree with that can you try to
like dissect that's what I mean when I
said I had many students but only one
Gordon Ryan like I've taught many many
people but they don't all have his skill
level so there's an obvious elephants in
the room be okay what distinguishes him
from from other athletes
great question I'll try and give an
answer
more than anyone else that I've ever
taught he has a memory
for things that were taught to him
he has an ability to recall information
that is extraordinary compared with
other people in the room so that's
definitely a big part of it
secondly he has a pride in technique and
Technical prowess
that will not allow him to settle for
anything less than Perfection and he
will hate himself when there is
imperfection
so there is a love of excellence and a
hatred of anything less than than
excellence
he has
an ability
to pull the trigger
when opportunity arises
which is truly extraordinary
many people know what to do but when the
moment comes
they back off
and they'll doubt themselves
if Gordon sees the opportunity the
trigger pulls every time
so again I just just link on that
absolutely there's a few times where he
gets a little bit of an advantage and he
just chases it to get a big like uh with
Andre gaval you know you get it's like
uh there's a dance and you get one step
ahead and he's able to chase that you
know get a little glimmer of the back
and he's able to chase that all the way
to back control
so that that is that kind of the trigger
that you're referring to yes it runs
deeper than that too it's the idea that
good athletes are greedy athletes
okay when they see a small opportunity
they try and get a as big a bite of it
as possible so that the manager that we
always have in training if you can see
the back you can take the back and if
Gordon sees an inch of your back
you know that's the duration he's going
to be going if your far shoulder is
within an inch of the floor he's going
to be mounting you uh if your shoulder
comes off the floor he'll be on your
back on the other side
um he's a maximalist with opportunity
he's not satisfied with oh let me get a
good enough outcome it's like I want the
maximal outcome so when you combine all
these things together an ability to
recall information
which is just
far superior to anyone else I've ever
coached
um an ability to
work in the training room towards not
just good technique but excellent
technique
the conference to pull the trigger
whenever the opportunity arises a
maximalist mindset where
It's never enough to have a good enough
outcome it's always got to be the best
possible outcome
and
The Fifth Element which I believe is
very very important
is
extraordinary depth
in his technical prowess
in particular with regards his defense
of Acumen everyone looks at Gordon and
focuses on his offensive prowess because
they see him dominate other athletes
but what they don't see is what I see
every day in the gym where he works from
impossibly Bad defensive positions
someone locked in on a full heel hook
on his body on a full Duty guitar me
Amber
and a complete pin mounted with Gordon's
two arms stretched out over his head in
what looks like a hopeless position
and Gordon will work in these positions
and of course because it's such a bad
position sometimes you'll have to tap
but he just works so relentlessly in
these bad positions that when he steps
on stage
he say
if this guy got the worst possible
position on me there's nothing he could
do with it and within 30 seconds I could
turn it around on him and win this match
um that gives his game
an overall breadth and depth which is
very very hard to deal with it means
there's no obvious weak point where you
can just say okay I'm going to attack
him here and use this strategy to to
beat them
um
and that goes back to uh his confidence
that
the reason why most people lack
confidence is they fear about bad
outcomes okay if if you're a strong
guard player
you've got an excellent guide but you're
terrified of leg logs and your opponent
has strong leg logs you will shut down
your own guard
and won't play as freely and well as you
normally do because you're afraid of the
leg lock danger you'll pull your feet in
You'll Play a very
conservative guard game
but if you had extremely adept
leg lock defense then you just play with
all the uh the confidence you normally
do from from guard position
um Gordon puts himself in that situation
he's so defensively sound
that it translates into his offense of
confidence
when you talk about memory recall which
is interesting I can't help but see
parallels between him and Magnus Carlson
who's a chess player who's the number
one in the world
the arguably the best ever certainly the
best ever if you just look absolute
numbers the chess has the luxury of
having a rating
which you can't have it cannot have in
Jiu Jitsu because it's a game of human
just chess is just a board game so you
can actually calculate the probability
that you could win so he is the highest
ELO rating uh ever and he's maintained
that rating he can without competing
against
the number two in the world he could
just prove that he's the number one in
the world for many years uh anyway
there's uh certain similarities one's
ability to re recall so memory recall of
information is fascinatingly good and
the other one is not so much a love for
Perfection which is something you
mentioned but yeah the flip side of that
which is what you also mentioned is the
hate of imperfection uh now in the case
of Magnus
it almost uh
creates a level of anxiety for him
that's almost destructive
so the thing he seems to hate the most
is imperfection against people he knows
are worse than him
so the thing he loves is competing
against people that are close to the
skill level or the favorite is people
who are might actually be better than
him especially in certain positions he
loves competing against them he hates
competing against people that are
um still from the perspective of
everyone else
uh what are called super Grand Master so
top three in the world but he knows he's
much better than them and the anxiety of
being not perfect against those people
that's why that's why he I don't know if
you're paying attention but he stepped
away he's not going to defend his world
championship
uh because he hates the anxiety of
playing people worse than him
interesting so he figures they would
somehow make him look bad or no he just
for him at least the language he uses is
just not fun
and he likes having fun it's to him it
was fun to win no matter the skill level
the world championship the first time
but then defending it is a very grueling
process
is
um
with classical chess you play these many
hours could be seven hour long games
and
uh on on top of that he really hates the
fact that it's only I forget what it is
but it's single digit number of games he
says it's it's low sample
so uh I can't
I would like to play 20 30 40 50 games
if we're going to do it this way but
then they're too long it's going to take
too long so he's really emphasizes the
the the fun of it and the clear
demonstration of who's the best now
chess
is an interesting game it's probably
different than grappling because it's
been played for centuries so there's
this giant body of people that are
playing it like there's other Gordon
Ryan's out there imagine a world where
there's multiple Gordon Ryan's or
something like that just different
dimensions but uh you have like sharks
everywhere and so there there is fun to
be had even at the very very very very
very top but the the memory recall is
the thing that stands out and the hate
of imperfection uh more intense than
anybody else in the game fascinating
that takes us back to the final ah yes
so uh here Gordon is facing uh Nikki Rod
former training Pana and
um again the intention here is this has
to be put in the context that Gordon
will be fighting the greatest ACC
Grappler of all time in a few hours
after this so what we're looking for is
a uh a quick
resolution
um still the shortest possible match now
there's a complicating Factor here Nikki
Rod was a wrestler before he was a jiu
jitsu player
on paper
the way his route to win is via
wrestling is not going to be able to
um
submit Gordon Ryan and he's knocking
about to pass his guard so he has to win
by wrestling
in the ADCC finals you cannot set to
guard so the the approach that Gordon
used earlier that we saw on video cannot
be used in the finals Gordon must
wrestle his opponent
so
on the way out
uh Gordon and I were talking and we'd
had discussions obviously during the
camp what's the appropriate thing to do
here
and there had been some
matches earlier in the event where it
was becoming obvious that stalling
was being heavily punished by referees
so
I said to Gordon on the way out just
give him your leg
let him take you down because in the
first 10 minutes of the finals takedowns
don't score anything well there are no
there are no means of scoring the first
10 minutes but you can't sit to God that
will be that will award you a negative
point so I said just let Nikki Royal
take you down and he's like Nikki Rod's
not going to take the bait and I said if
he doesn't they'll call him for stalling
and so and and then Craig Jones also
commented after the fact is I don't know
why Nikki took the beat
um so if we see the start of the match
you see Gordon comes out and offers a
leg now it's not that you know Nikki
right is smart he knows what's happening
here and uh what's he going to do store
for 10 minutes and get like five
restoring calls put against them so
Gordon gives them the takedown that way
they go to the ground immediately with
no effort and the match now favors
Gordon because Gordon is
uh significantly more skilled on the
ground
um
the question is how can we make this
match as short as possible and as is so
often the case the answer comes back to
legs
so uh for people just listening to this
Gordon is in an open guard and nicarad
appears to be trying to keep his hips
away from Gordon's legs yes the big
Nikki Rod knows there's a danger here so
he's elected to go to his knees that
will set up his favorite body lock
passes and it will in some ways mitigate
some of the dangers associated with leg
locks so Gordon's whole thing is how am
I going to get my body weight underneath
them here's a choice between linear
entries where he enters between his
opponent's knees and circular entries
where he inverts and Spins underneath
his opponent to get under a center of
gravity is is there a way for somebody
to try to get a body lock without giving
Gordon an opportunity to get under under
them uh well the body lock is an
excellent way to shut down leg lock
entries if you can get to the body lock
but you can see Gordon's very very
disciplined with his elbow and knee
position elbows and knees are working in
a position where it's very very hard for
his opponent to access his waste
that shoulder is always either across
the hip or in front of the shoulder
sorry his knee is either in front of the
shoulder or in front of the hip and
we're one minute into the match and just
if I were to look at the video player
here it appears that the match is over
soon so uh
so I guess Nicki Wright is facing this I
need to get close in order to do the uh
the body lock and the closer you get the
more danger there is
uh to let Gordon get uh under you and
get the leg control
foreign
to get close here Gordon's going to try
and get his head underneath this
opponent make a circular entry into the
legs
he's clearing his opponent's head out of
the way by faking the arm drag on the
far side the first move that he used
against his uh first opponent earlier in
the tournament and there's the leg spins
underneath it
go circular rotates through gets his
body weight underneath his opponent okay
now he's going to trip him down to the
mat now uh I believe Nigeria tries to
pull out his foot here
and Craig also said that nicarad has
gotten used to being able to pull that
foot out from anybody and that he was
very surprised at the grip
that that Gordon was able to actually
hold on
so I just want to comment I'm I'm just
I'm just parroting commentary um if you
look at what's happening here from the
internet uh just if you just freeze it
you'll see that Gordon like any good leg
Locker will always treat his opponent's
foot like a knot at the end of the Rope
just as you slide down a rope if there's
a knot at the end your hand will catch
yeah so too with the human leg when they
go to extract by pulling you just keep
your fist is close to your shoulder
shoulder as possible and narrow the Gap
the foot will always catch the failure
that many people have is they let their
hand drift away from their own shoulder
and so there's room for the foot to
extract but you'll see Gordon's
extremely disciplined with thumb close
to his own shoulder which creates a
situation that's very very hard just to
simply pull your foot out you're you're
focusing on the knot of the foot yeah
also it's very early in the match
there's very little sweat both athletes
are still pretty dry
now Gordon has to climb the leg
and now he's already captured his
opponent's shoelace there's the heel
exposure coming up Nikki Rod already
knows things are getting bad
and there's the win actually the comment
I made I guess was from a little bit
earlier there was an earlier time where
Nikki while I was trying to pull out the
foot and the Gordon's able to hold on to
the knot
um which which is interesting
now that was uh
a brilliant day's work by Gordon Ryan he
said two matches against opponents
considerably bigger and stronger than
himself
and uh the time of the two matches can
be measured in
I think less than two minutes so he's
he's done what he's set out to do no
injuries no exhaustion he's beaten four
guys back to back all of whom are
excellent athletes with minimal energy
expenditure and he's ready to go on to
his super fight
so uh and that's against uh one of the
greatest arguably for a long time you
know uh really really up there uh Jiu
Jitsu practitioners competitors
grappling no geek competitors of all
time which is Andre govow yes Andre
govows uh almost certainly at this point
the the greatest ADCC competitor of all
time won more Super fights than anyone
else by a landslide
so I if I may just read a few words
you've written on Instagram about this
match about Andre gaval on greatness how
great you become in any given Endeavor
will always be assessed by the degree of
difficulty of the barriers you have to
overcome to get to the top just as the
lion became king of the jungle not by
living among sheep but by dominating a
world of elephants hyenas Buffalo
leopards crocodiles so too the greatness
of an athlete will be determined not
just by his own ability but by the
greatness of the athletes he faces thus
in his quest for greatness Gordon Ryan
owes a debt to the greatness of his
toughest opponent Andre galvao and you
go on to sing him Praises so and that
introduces this match you know there was
a interesting moment I didn't even
um
listen to the wars exchanged but because
I had the great Fortune of sitting next
to hacho crazy there was this uh
uh fascinating moment before the match
and I can't believe Gordon has
sufficiently relaxed to do this but he
walked up to uh Hydra Gracie and had a
discussion what do you think you Face
Hunter Goa before what are your
suggestions and they've talked to back
and forth they brainstormed ideas like
minutes before the match and it was just
a beautiful moment of like I don't know
like like Tiger Woods and Michael Jordan
talking to each other something like
that I mean I wonder how much
brainstorming there really was or and
how much was it just kind of um
ins like spiritual inspiration or
something like that yeah the I think
it's more spiritual inspiration he looks
after as a uh uh who's a very close
friend a mentor of mine so I always tell
my athletes look to harder as your
example this is a guy who
always fought for the Finish he tried to
express the the highest ideal of Jiu
Jitsu which is control leading to
submission and every match he was ever
in he even lost matches on tactics
against people that he could easily have
defeated if he adopted a different
tactic but he always insisted on Victory
by submission it defined his career made
of who who he was and I always try to
have my athletes emulate him
so what was the strategy going into this
match what were you thinking were you
okay uh for Andre Galvan
he
hit there's a sense in which Andre gavon
had to fight literally the perfect match
to win this okay this this is a match
that's going to be 20 minutes long
um and potentially 40 minutes long
um
Andre gomon cannot win by submission
Gordon's submission
dominance here is is just too great
uh it would be exceedingly difficult for
him to win on the ground uh Gordon's
ground positional game is just too
advanced and so for Andre Galvan he had
to win if he was going to win it was
going to be in a standing wrestling
exchange where most people assist him as
having a measure of superiority over
Gordon Ryan
the problem is
that
it's hard
to just keep a potentially 40 minute
match on the ground sorry off the ground
that whole time it's it's very very
difficult indeed so he would have had to
fight literally the perfect tactical
match to make it happen and he would
have to do it without getting called
restoring points
um
Gordon has the luxury that if at any
point they go to the ground he has
complete dominance but Gordon too has a
problem that he can't pull guard without
being penalized and uh if Andre Galvan
can play this tactical game of forcing
Gordon to pull guard
and then
staying at a distance where he doesn't
he's doing enough action not to get
called for stalling but not so much to
engage with the dangerous Gordon Ryan on
the ground then it's feasible he could
have won
but it would have been as I said it
would have required the most perfect
application and integration of technique
and tactics
that that he's capable of
how much intimidation was here
was there uh or are these assets already
beyond that uh when you say intimidation
be more precise
do you think there is some degree if
you're just to empathize with Andre
gaval do you think there's some degree
in which Gordon was in his head
um because of the Trash Talk leading up
to certain events because of the level
of dominance that Gordon has shown in
this competition and in uh
months and years leading up to it also
the fact that Andre gaval is also a
coach of a large team so there's some
pressure to demonstrate to the team
that the old line still got it yeah
um I can't speak for Andre but uh I know
for Gordon
it's hard to be intimidated when you
know the other guy has no method of
finishing you
it's it just takes so much pressure off
when you just go and you're saying
there's literally no way this guy can
finish me
um
and there's no way this guy can pin and
control me I can't be finished I can't
be pinned and controlled
the only way I can lose this
is if this guy plays a tactical game
so in his best case scenario
I lose my Tactical
by a tactical game but from Andre's
perspective it's like if I make one
screw up this kid could finish me
like it's you can see which way the
intimidation game goes
now for the start things get interesting
here we've already said if you can just
freeze it right there
Andre's only real realistic part to
Victory is standing grappling okay that
would require him to take Gordon down
presumably multiple times after the
first 10 minutes and not be taken down
at all by Gordon so it's a tall order
it's possible but difficult
and here's where things get interesting
I told Gordon before the match
just go out and offer in the league same
we did with Nikki rod
and that's where things get interesting
I must say that I loved what Andre
Galvan did at the start of this match
he's a little crazy here this is there
was just so much energy in the room at
this point that his hand finding God oh
for people just listening there's uh
there's a bit of hard slapping yeah that
could be considered a strike that's fine
it's um there was just a lot of electric
atmosphere in the room so now things
settle down a little bit
um but here's where things get
interesting Andre
throws the whole tactical game out the
window right from the start
he goes for the takedown Gordon doesn't
try to fight the takedown because it's
in his interests to go to the ground but
this I love this about Andre he's
literally like [ __ ] you kid
like let's see how good your ground game
is yeah so he shoots the takedown
um and Gordon accepts it obviously
because it's to his advantage to accept
it
but I love the fact that Andre was like
I'm not even going to try and stole this
out I'm just going to bang there it is
so he's like okay let's see what you got
kid they say you're good on the ground
let's see what you [ __ ] got and I
love that about Andre
unfortunately he's entered the uh The
Hornet's Nest now what happened there
real quick because that was very Gordon
immediately went into ashigrami not just
any ashigurami but ashirami was holding
both legs so it's an open guard and he
scooted forward oh wow that's really
nice so it's against the legs now he
dominates the space between the knees so
there's a guaranteed straight out sugar
Army here
he split the knees against Andre galvao
like effortlessly right there
wow
so already Gordon's in his preferred
domain now so he's starting to off
balance his opponent he's looking for
reaction to get heel exposure he does
get heel exposure Andre's uh does a good
job of monitoring defeat to try and
reduce the braking pressure but the The
Brute fact is it's in Gordon's realm now
this is this is where he has all the
advantage so um and the match is going
to be 20 minutes of in Gordon's realm
that's going to be a very very tall
order
foreign
was there a moment here
again Gordon's on the legs
are you impressed that Andre was able to
get out from this country I would expect
this on Andre's been preparing for this
for two years and um uh he remember
Andre is going against some of the
greatest uh leg Locus and grappling
before and Prevail so he's he's not
naive you know he knows how to defend
himself
um the big problem is that he's going to
create defensive reactions which lead
into other aspects of Gordon's game in
particular back exposure so here uh
ashigrami goes to like a single leg type
of position where Gordon Runs to Andre's
back
now it has to return them to the mat the
most efficient way to do so is always
courtesy of foot sweeping so he pulls
out a DIY from the back to sweeten down
to the man
and now Gordon's on top and this
is a serious problem for any Grappler in
the world once Gordon gets top position
he's just relentless
but just getting Andre gavar's good just
getting the guard back all of that is
great there's also a sensor in which
Gordon is pacing it too just to
physically fatigue an opponent
so I was passing the guards but not
rushing it
now what Gordon's looking for here is
complete chest to Chase contact
he's getting very close to it now
and once he gets chest to chased on an
opponent in top position past one of his
opponent's knees it's going to be
awfully awfully difficult for an
opponent to recover
what is he waiting for here is the this
pressure here over time he just wears
you out yeah it's part of a campaign of
attrition of pressure over time now he's
creating a situation where he's he's
either going to get back exposure or
Mount exposure and either way is pretty
much fatal when you're dealing with
Gordon
um Andre elected to to go the route of
back exposure
now Gordon got the body triangle is on
his back
and now it's uh now there's one physical
problem here that's uh that Andre Galvan
has a neck like a bull and um he's a
very short and very thick neck so
penetrating under the chin for the
strangle can be a real problem he also
has extremely well developed shoulders
and upper arms so when the head comes
down and the shoulders go up there's
very little real estate to work with
with regards to strangleholds so Gordon
in time will trap one of his opponent's
arms with his legs in order to take away
one of those strong defensive arms there
you can see the arm has been trapped and
now he can see the biting towards the
strangle
and now here is still difficult it's
still difficult but um things are
looking good there's still a
considerable amount of time left on the
clock Gordon as well ahead on points so
all the pressure all the Tactical
pressure now is on Andre
you'll see the critical penetration of
the jaw with the wrist there wow yeah
I'll go in the legs for a one-handed
strangle
foreign
very bravely
but
a strangle it doesn't matter how Brave
you are and where where does the
strangle actually happen in terms of
um
it felt like the strangle was at the
blade of the it wasn't even fully sunk
in yeah so where does is that like a
full car was like um one-handed there's
a sense in which once you get underneath
you know the inevitable yeah follow-up
is again the inevitable you're feeling
the inevitable it's like a um to go back
to your chest analogy it's like
resigning in cheers yeah and chess is
considered almost like impolite to let
let it run out when you understand yeah
when you understand that death is
on the horizon
and there's a lot of
there's a lot of respect that was the
beautiful thing with all the trash talk
and everything like that Gordon always
shows respect I love that
um about the drama of combat
is trash talk in the beginning and
respect at the end I think it's you know
when you when you feel someone uh Andre
has great skills and uh when you when
you grapple someone you feel just how
skilled they are and um uh it whatever
issues you had prior to the match
evaporate when you when you feel that
okay they're just like you they do the
same moves and same kind of Concepts and
and you see that there's more that bonds
you together than separates you and
that's the feeling that the end of most
grappling matches so if we could
talk about Giancarlo who had an
incredible performance and I mean
there's a lot of things we can say we
can probably go through his matches but
if we could just talk without that about
some of the most impressive things he
saw about him one of the things I think
you mentioned uh elsewhere in here is
about confidence so one of the things
you saw that could really benefit him as
an Athen and competitor is to build up
his confidence is there uh can you speak
to that first of all I should give you
some background uh John Carlo bedoni was
a um uh a strong
uh local black belt in Boston
um teaching at Bernardo Faria school
when I would film instructional videos I
would often talk to him and talk to him
about his competitions and training and
he would do local competitions he was
trying to go from gear training which
was the majority of his competitive
background into nogi and he was
struggling uh in local competitions
especially for things like leg locking
where he had no background and leg
lock-in and would often get submitted so
as we work together in instructional
videos we we would talk and discuss how
it would periodically come to the gym in
New York City and come in to work out
with the guys and
um he often struggled in the training
room he had no experience with things
like body like guard passing and this
used to uh mean that he was uh many of
the training sessions didn't go well for
him
um
so it was always like a very polite
well-spoken young man and uh worked hard
um
when we went to Puerto Rico and the team
ended up drifting apart
um
when we moved into Austin uh
he he said you know now that
many of your athletes have left could I
come down and train with you guys full
time and I was like yeah I'd love to I
thought it'd be a great training partner
for Gordon and Gary we didn't really
have any training Partners at that point
and
um uh sure enough he literally just
picked up everything he had and moved
down to Austin
um now anyone who just moves halfway
across the country to begin training
that already gets my respect right there
that's a big commitment and
um uh he began training we put him on a
uh a training schedule where first he
had to cover up his big weaknesses he
had limited attacks from uh bottom
position he had poor leg lock defense
and he was very very vulnerable to
um certain kinds of guard passing which
weren't part of his experience this is
all a year out from agcc yes and we
should also maybe
uh give the the spoiler which is he wins
his division in a dominant fashion
he also does incredibly well at the
absolute
you know it was an amazing thing um to
give you an idea when he first moved to
Austin he competed in um
wno event and I don't think he scored a
single point lost a couple of matches
and
um uh and including matches to people
who were in this ADCC so
um uh he came out of that looking very
depressed and uh he lost the Canon
Duarte he lost to um uh Mason Fowler so
Giancarlo always struck me someone who
was positionally sound he he had like
good guard retention things like this
but he had no offense he had no leglock
defense and he just wasn't able to
assert Authority on matches he was he
was a guy who's always going to be tough
to be because he was hard to pass his
guard that kind of thing but he wasn't
dangerous can I ask you a question on
that yeah because my interaction with
him uh early on when he came to Austin
I remember he interacted me a bunch on
the mat showing me stuff but I wonder if
that kindness is a detriment to the
confidence is there some connection
again Killers can be nice too absolutely
confidence comes from skill level and
um uh confidence is much more
rational thing that most people ascribe
people think of confidence is like this
esoteric ethereal element that you
either have or you don't when in fact
confidence is much more a reflection a
rational reflection on your past
experience and if you're successful with
your past experience and you're
expecting to
uh
compete in a situation which is similar
to your past experience and that past
experience has mostly been successful
you'll be confident are you pretty
confident that the sun will rise
tomorrow of course you are because it's
done so every time in the past now
there's no
as people like Hume pointed out there's
no Supreme rational reason for for
believing this but nonetheless your
confidence is high and it's the same
thing in Jiu Jitsu
um if if you're performing well and
skills are uh the reason for that your
confidence will be high in the future
regardless of what your mindset is so
it's not a question of you know this
personality does better in competition
or that personality ultimately it's
going to come down to your skills and um
and your confidence will be a reflection
of your accumulation of skills
so what was his journey like to a person
who lost to a person who dominated the
competition yeah first things first we
had to say okay you've got an obvious
weakness leg lock defense so
um every day in the gym he would be
taught okay this is where you put your
feet this is where you position your
knees your point you need this way not
this way
um uh then he would have to start
sparring situations in leg locks and
have to work his way out
um initially these were like
heartbreaking
sessions for him where I mean I've got
to give that kid full credit like he
just worked his way through it patiently
dealt with frustration initial failures
and just said I'm going to get better
can we just look on that so what's the
experience of those early training
sessions like foreign
thought that you're not going to ever be
good yeah you're wondering have I even
got what it takes like you you think
about it he's an established player
who's been an ibj of competition I
believe he's a brown belt world champion
in the ghee
um and suddenly a group of kids
that he's never even seen before
repeatedly submitting them with leg logs
yeah in the gym and he's like man this
this is terrible like a year from now
I'm supposed to fight 80cc against
people like
Craig Jones like some of the best league
Lockers in the world like it must have
been hard you know
um
but he just stayed in there and no one
worked harder than him he just was in
the gym three times a day studying every
day and unlike so many other people
every time he was showing something he
consciously and deliberately tried to
enact it even at the price of initial
failure do you advise that that's a good
way to go it's the only way to go
like if you if you can't wrap your head
around the idea
that trying to acquire new skills will
create a temporary time where your
Effectiveness diminishes as you're
trying to bring on new skills you're
never going to make it because you'll
always stay at whatever skill set you
are
the whole mental trick is to is to
imbue this idea of delayed gratification
that you have to accept that when I
bring on new moves
My overall effectiveness will diminish
but there's the belief that in time as
my skill performance increases it will
increase over time but it will come at
the price of initial frustration and
failure and John Carlo made that mental
uh switch early on in his time in Austin
and to his credit just stuck through
within a very short period of time he
came very hard to lay Lock And even the
best leg Lockers in the room had a hard
time with them and that's that was the
first step in confidence to say okay I'm
not getting finished quickly anymore
then he had to bring in a whole new set
of uh upper body submissions he
neglected upper body submissions when
you sell property submissions do you
mean novel holds arm locks things like
this and um uh in particular put very
very hard work on his strangleholds
um he had always been someone who was
positionally strong he could get to the
back but he could never finish from the
back and then suddenly in the Jeremy
started finishing from the back and then
as gym performance against the Lesser
students increased then you bump him up
against better students and then this
goes on all the way up to the best guys
in the room
and uh in time in a relatively short
period of time there was significant
increases in performance and uh success
begets success and this kept going
we started to get a hint of
his developing confidence in local
competitions I remember putting Saint
John Carlo compete in a local fight to
win competition against the tough
Brazilian kid John Carter just came out
dominated and finished with a leg lock
now that was that was interesting to say
okay
you're the guy that used to get finished
by leg logs and now you're beating tough
opponents with leg locks and that was an
important psychological step for
Giancarlo bedoni and um
uh with each little step as we went
further and further uh then he got to
80cc trials and had one of the Great
Performances
um I believe he submitted all of his
opponents and ADCC trials and uh put on
a fantastic display of grout Lane
shockingly
no one paid attention to it
they were just like oh yeah he won and
no John Kelly flew into ADCC completely
under the radar they just saw him as oh
he's the guy that won American trials
and uh no one really paid much attention
um in his first match he took on a great
um uh Brazilian Champion uh izaki and um
uh one in dominant fashion he was about
to strangle him with just a few seconds
left on the clock and I remember John
color being furious at the end of the
match
um thinking like I was so close to
finishing he wanted a perfect finish and
uh up on point six to nothing yeah and
uh still Chase still chasing I mean he
could have just coasted at this point
but he wanted to finish every one of his
opponents and uh he got very very close
but not quite there
and um
then in his next match he had to take on
the defending gold medalist from the
previous uh uh uh ADCC amateurs and
years this was the guy who was the
favorite to win so you have a relatively
unknown John Carlo fighting the man who
defeated Craig Jones in the previous
ADCC
what do you remember what stood out to
you about this match
um is good wrestling is good everything
yeah good all the wrong Grappler uh he's
got uh by Jujitsu standards he's a very
strong race list so Our intention was to
match his wrestling with John Carter's
uh uh Judo skills so
um you'll see if we could
um perhaps go back
you'll see the first uh takedown
foreign
drag
and took him down with a simple dragon
pick so that was John Keller's uh first
takedown that was more wrestling
oriented and good for his confidence to
see that he could score a nice take down
but um uh Matthias Denise is very very
good at standing up from bottom position
if we just go back to the stamp okay now
here we have something interesting
Matthias comes up from bottom sees her
leg and John Carlo defends the wrestling
move and then goes immediately into what
the [ __ ] with a it's kind of a mix of
society and uh that was beautiful I
didn't even notice that that's really
nice look at that
from from uh defending a single
threatening a guillotine
one of the big themes of our ADCC Camp
was that most of our opponents now
getting very strong in hand fighting
look at that but they are not strong in
foot fighting
and so we put a very heavy emphasis on
on uh foot sweeping attacks you'll
remember Gordon Ryan took down Andre
Galvan with a foot sweep and here you
have John Carlo using the same uh
technique not from the back but from the
front and the Nova hook uh
look at and it's just a beautiful
beautiful takedown that's beautiful Judo
and then uh and then later on the match
you'll use a kosaragake another
classical Judo takedown to get top
position
now at one point Giancarlo was in
trouble
he got his back exposed
with this situation good
double leg to uh to a knee Pig
so he has to uh expose his back in order
to avoid giving up takedown points but
here's a defensive training that we work
on is is coming through
he's defensively sound shuts out the
hook prevents a score
keeps his body at the right angle to
prevent a power half Nelson
staying calm
now he's got to turn this around
it's one of the hardest things to do in
grappling
how dangerous is it to put your uh in
this position to put your hands on the
ground
um it's ordinarily it could be dangerous
because your opponent could switch to a
number oops and there's the body log now
there's some controversy here but you
can clearly see it uh the hands were
locked so it shouldn't really be as
controversial as people are saying now
watch for the right leg because sort of
Gaga here pulls in the hips exposes the
leg boom and down
beautiful Coast Guard game
also probably a lesson that uh
complaining to a ref does not protect
you from a good Tick Tock yeah that's
why they're saying Combat Sports defend
yourself at all times
um but now the the great advantage of of
Judo takedowns over wrestling Lake
tackles is they confirm upper body
connection after the takedown which is
very very important for ADCC that's why
we put such a heavy emphasis on them and
um now John Carlos is absolutely in the
driver's seat he discovered four points
for that takedown so he's well ahead at
this point against the established
favorite for the entire weight division
so now Matthias Denise has to start
taking some risks he's staring down the
barrel of defeat there's not that much
time left and that's what's going to set
up the the pressure now it's tactical
pressure it's not physical pressure it's
Tactical Matthias has to turn away
and that's going to create back exposure
the most dangerous kind of exposure in
ADCC
oh there it is
Mount to back
and uh
Giancarlo capitalizes
Mateus is smart he's keeping on the side
so that less than 75 percent of his back
is on the floor to deny the uh the
mountain points but that comes at a
price and that price is back exposure so
the thing we talked about with Gordon
the the circumstance of Fate which is he
has a lot of grueling tough matches and
still chooses to do absolute so what's
and he seems to just power through all
of it what how much of it
how much of the calculation is how to
survive the cardio the grueling cardio
aspect of all of this that's uh it's a
great question and the truth of the
matter is you can't
forward to pace yourself
because if you say I'm going to hold
myself back for this match an
expectation of the others you could end
up losing your first match so he didn't
Pierce himself at all any of the matches
you have to just be in good shape and
that's what they're they're going on
no it's mostly physical you've that's
what the camp is for like he's felt more
pressure in the training room that he
felt in any of his matches
but still sort of attacking look at this
from back or from whatever the heck that
position was
uh a rate for uh from looking for the
back transitioning here what the heck is
this transition so Matthias is engaging
in a very good tactic which is to get
most of his back off the ground to deny
the amount points so as back exposure
starts okay he turns in threatening yeah
but you can see what's happening here is
the left foot goes under it's going to
create a beautiful triangle entry
right foot penetrates through underneath
the neck
and now he's locking a triangle a
senkaku but not just any triangle a
triangle with the the figure four locked
on the back of the opponent's head which
makes any kind of stacking defense very
very difficult it makes it very very
hard for an opponent to pull away and
creates a much tighter strangle than
average
and as a result it's a quick submission
beautifully done still chasing the
submission yes uh with a minute left up
on points against the former Champion
against the former Champion that's match
number two now that's the first day
that's Saturday so John Kohler goes to
sleep that night thinking okay I just
beat a world champion in my first match
and almost submitted him and I just
submitted the defending Champion so of
course he wakes up on Sunday morning
feeling pretty damn good now there's an
interesting twist here his opponent is a
talented young Irishman who won European
trials I believe almost entirely with
leg logs and almost all of his major
attacks in the tournament so far have
been leglocks now bear in mind that a
year ago John Carter was losing to local
blue belt competitors via leglock yeah
so in my mind I'm thinking okay how's he
going to handle this is with the leg
lock training kick in and you'll see the
result
foreign
Owen from Ireland is employing the same
tactics that we made famous uh years ago
the idea of sitting the butterfly garden
looking to entangle the legs he's kind
of playing that game so um so John
Carter is obviously used to this from
training the gym so he's doing a good
job of preventing entanglement a
controlling his opponent shoelaces and
moving out to an angle which limits his
opponent's entry options so hands on the
shoelaces and angles is a good defense
here
it's an initial defense now his opponent
wants to get underneath the center of
gravity so John Carlo wants to get
outside the uh the line of his legs at
some point your opponent is going to
entangle if he's determined to entangle
at some point it's going to happen so
John Carter decides okay let's let it
happen
and let's see where his feet go and
let's see how disciplined he is with his
feet
and the opponent is inverted
uh here does a good job getting behind
John Carlo's knee
so now they're fully logged in so John
Cullen moves away to protect the heel
rotates out and controls the shoelace
now at this point the irishman's
starting to lose discipline with his own
foot position okay he's so focused on
his own attack that he's starting to get
a little sloppy with his own foot
possession you see he's assuming oh I'm
the guy who's attacking so my opponent
will be afraid of my leg logs and is
starting to make some small technical
errors that John Carter will take
advantage of so he's threatening the
sort of the north-south passer
like uh
yeah yeah it's not putting too much
pressure on the past because we're still
pretty early in the match and
um he's not ready to score yet so here
again he turns away his heel now his
opponent's starting to get more and more
Cavalier with his foot positioning to a
point where now it's just downright
sloppy
so Giancarlo sees it identifies it locks
up a wrist to wrist Toe Hold and breaks
his foot
how how
where's the
dumb question where's the control here
how is he the control comes from his
opponent the entanglement is his
opponent's ah his opponent is holding
his own body in place with his own legs
so he's the root of his own problem here
so you got sloppy well done well done
and a little smile from drunk that was
very nice the reason for that smile you
can probably guess is because
a year ago
this would have been a disaster and now
instead it's a guaranteed ticket to the
finals in either a gold or a silver
medal and so you can see in that
compressed moment that's the look of a
man who's made was just recognized as
how much progress he's made and what was
once a weakness in roughly 10 months was
the time it took and so uh he faces
Lucas Hulk Barbosa in the in in the
final here now these do have a history
um Hulk is beaten uh John Carlin many
times and um so for John Carlo it's a
question of okay
here I'm matched up against a guy who's
repeatedly beaten me
how am I how am I going to turn this
around now and in terms of we talked
earlier about confidence if confidence
was just a mental thing
Giancarlo never would have won this
fight when you've lost all those times
to to an athlete
um words aren't going to change anything
but you can see right from the start
when they get into the hand fight John
Carlo is much more technically Adept
with his hand fighting he's doing a good
job of controlling his opponent's hands
preventing any kind of prolonged
pressure on the head and
the Hulk gets a sense here in which he
realizes he's fighting a very different
person
and this goes this goes a long time
again another Super grueling match
wrestling
that eventually leads to a back take
care back triangle
body drawing up on this
here you can see the same tactics
utilized by um golden Ryan
back control based around the body trial
many attempts to try and entrap his
opponent's arm and take away those
defensive arms the main difference here
is again you have an athlete with a very
powerful compact neck so neck
penetration is difficult and so John
Carl will switch to a a palm to Palm
strangle instead of the conventional
figure four
and uh now there's eight minutes left so
all the time in the world
is it only just a matter of time at this
point in situations like this yeah John
Carter has a massive tactical lead and
points there's literally no way he could
lose this match at this point
um even if his opponent did get out of
here and take him down
John Carter would still be a hit on
points
so at this question the question now is
not whether John Carter will get the
gold medal but whether John Carter will
will get it by submission and there it
is there's the penetration of the neck
and he can't get the figure four so he
asks for Palms Apartment instead and
there's the submission
now what a journey what is it John
Carlo's a relatively unemotional man but
you can see there's there's emotion
that's not fake that's genuine and
that's the emotions of a man who
10 months ago couldn't have done that
and then 10 months later by Dent of his
own hard work and and dedication and uh
his ability to to actively attack his
weaknesses and turn them into strengths
and then develop an ability to uh to to
finish
that that was a truly truly remarkable
achievement
let me ask you about
um garyton
so he is one of the
at least in my opinion the greatest
submission Grapplers of all time there's
a lot of components to that but he lost
in his first match not only did Gary
lose he lost to the Bottom seed of his
Division and that in itself is something
pretty remarkable about what's happening
in ADCC how
there's a sense in which the days of
the invited athletes being far superior
to the trials winners are over it was a
clear signal that anyone who makes it to
ADCC can beat the best people
um Sam McNally is a very talented uh
submission Grappler from Ireland he
specializes mostly in arm bars but he
has a good positional game as well
there's a very modern look to his uh to
his Jiu Jitsu and uh he did a fantastic
job against garitonin
I think technically uh Gary perhaps got
a little far away from
uh
his true nature and grappling which is
Relentless submission attack and perhaps
uh I should be
given blame for this because they put
such a heavy emphasis on the in the
training camp overall on positional
pressure that I feel that worked very
well for all of the athletes except Gary
tonan and um interesting so his his name
you have to acknowledge the nature of
the athletes part and I think I was
coaching so hard to the to the new
people in the room on positional
pressure that I neglected Gary's uh
innate ability to it the fact that he
does best when he um attacks exclusively
by submission so I think if if anyone
should get blamed for the failure here
it should be me uh there's another
comment as uh maybe I'm over
um
overvaluing that sort of just the
physical aspect of this but it seemed
like Gary was looked skinny is is the
weight cut yeah he
um this is the first time I ever went
down to the uh 66 kilos so
um you know it wasn't critical these
other guys who were bigger than him who
made the weight
um but the weight cut if you can just
comment on is that does that ever play a
part in the athletes the the physical
and the mental aspect of the weight cut
it is it is a thing can wrestling That
Could Break Even some of the toughest
Minds yeah but no it wasn't a white cat
that would break someone like Garrett's
owner and it was it's more physical you
you train lighter and weaker you tend to
get injured more in Camp because you're
lighter
um we have a team now after the breakout
that's mostly comprised of people over
215 pounds so um uh there's very few
small people left in the gym most of the
smaller athletes went uh to B team so
um uh Gary's been struggling a little
bit with with training partners and um
uh but here I think the chief problem
was that uh Gary focused perhaps a
little too much on the positional
tactical game and got away from his his
true gift which is uh uh Relentless
hunting for submissions and as I said I
think the person to blame for that is me
because I put I had to put so much
emphasis on the positional game for the
for the developing athletes that um I
didn't pay enough attention to Gary's
unique attributes so this uh I mentioned
I posted some stuff on Reddit so there's
a relevant question here uh somebody on
Reddit asked Gordon has said and perhaps
you have said as well there are two
types of Jiu Jitsu practitioners ones
who move themselves around like Marcel
Garcia and ones that control the motion
of their opponents like Gordon
um what are the strengths and weaknesses
of each approach and how do those
different approaches apply depending on
which way class you're in that's a great
set of questions yes um uh I'm the
person who promulgates this idea that
there's two broad ways you can go on
Jiu-Jitsu you can either
focus on
promoting your own movement to create
opportunity or by restricting the other
person's movement
if you're a slower
less athletic opponent
then you should definitely focus on the
idea of restricting the other fellows
movement that's how slow unathletic
people win in Jiu-Jitsu if you're quick
with the ability to change direction
stand up quickly go down quickly
and move like a leopard then you're
almost always better off generating
movement
in order to create opportunity so one is
based more on movement as the the source
of opportunity one is based more upon
pressure as the source of opportunity so
you'll get someone like Gary Turnin or
the ruatolo brothers their game is based
around the idea of promoting their own
movement to create opportunity whereas
someone like Gordon Ryan or Hydra Grace
is about restricting movement and using
that pressure
to create reactive opportunity those are
the two paths you can take in Jiu Jitsu
because our team now has become mostly
associated with people over 200 pounds
and because most of them will begin as I
took the more high percentage approach
of okay let's uh let's focus primarily
on controlling the other fellows
movement and
um uh but Gary is a unique individual
and I feel like I let him down by not uh
Giving Him special attention in in
regards to to what he does the fact that
you've mentioned is now like four times
in the in the span of a few minutes just
I love that that that all of the stuff
will be so heavy on you
um and he is a truly special person it
is truly interesting to see what is the
nature of a particular athlete that if
you highlight makes them shine let's go
to the part where Gary actually loses
the match okay so the match is pretty
innocuous at this point the guy does a
good job of turning into the arm
and um
Gary gets caught reaching from the knees
okay that's always a mistake and uh the
guy does I think he does a great job
capitalizing on it now there's there's
limited time left on the clock this guy
realizes oh this is my opportunity he's
got good flexibility and he gets the
Hawks if we just freeze it right there
so there's a minute and a half left and
typically an 80cc if you get the bag you
score three points so uh this is a huge
score
um for Gary to win here it's got to be
by submission okay so Gary's made one
mistake now
um this talented young fellow from
Ireland does a great job not only of
getting the bag but he really attacks
well from the back and let's look at the
depth of garyton's defensive Acumen here
and we should say leading up to this his
defense is incredible yeah he's keeping
escaping evidence a nickname for Gary is
the slippery salmon because he's like
trying to hold a goddamn salmon on the
riverbank trying to hold on to this kid
so he gets into a position which looks
absolutely hopeless here it gets worse
this is already bad but
um
um it's one of the most fun things about
to watch while Gary is the skill and the
escapes it's incredible it's it's
beautiful to watch so the guy has an
excellent opportunity to transition off
him into a rare triangle which is one of
the hardest things in the world to get
out of and from here if this was anyone
but Gary tone and I think it would have
been curtains but you see Gary just
extends keeps his arm at the just the
right angle to pop out and gets out so
now Gary's like oh crap I'm gonna lose
to this [ __ ] guy so he's got a minute
left to do something so he goes back
into his submission mode he goes back to
who Gary Tillman is and immediately goes
into leg lock action
now
the the uh the young man from Ireland
realizes hey I'm going to win this match
against the number one seed so Gary goes
into the legs
gets to one of his favorite techniques
the the heel hook
now Gary has a brutal heel hook his egg
and gets real pressure on the kid's leg
oh oh it's hard to watch yeah but to his
credit the kid is smart he's like you
know what let me uh he's just let me
take some let me take some zero weakness
to that like well he turned his hips
yeah it's unclear from the video whether
Gary's uh um slipped up with his
considerable braking pressures oh it
slipped yeah yeah it's unclear even
before but sometimes the heel can slip
because it's because something's popped
so it's unclear what happened there
there seems to be a reaction from the
part of the opponent like it definitely
did some damage so Gary goes back for a
second one oh no and again you get that
same kind of pressure oh no oh right but
I I like I like the Irish kids reaction
though he's just like you know what let
me eat this because I'm gonna win this
match and I'm gonna be a legend for
beating Gary Tony so I admired his
internal fortitude and um but now Gary
knows he's lost it so it there's a
sensor in which you you see how
close it gets in these situations how
little there is between winner and loser
and sometimes you just get these
heartbreaking
situations where someone who ordinarily
you would probably do very well against
and you make one mistake and it's an
it's an unrewarding uncompromising sport
one mistake can be fatal in class you
talked about escapes for arm locks and
applies here as well uh so you were
teaching armalk escapes and I think uh
uh choke escapes uh and the question
came up when should an athlete not tap
and risk their arm being broken and you
quoted George Patton as of course you
would that no bastard ever won a war by
dying for his country he wanted by
making some other Bastard die for his
country so what's your view on when to
tap and when not not to tap in
competition first off in in training you
should be tapping very early because
um uh you know getting paid to fight in
the gym you're getting paid to fight on
stage so be a professional in the gym
step early tap fast that way you'll
you'll last a lot longer in competition
things were a little different we also
have to specify what is the situation
okay if you're in the first round of
ADCC your first match you get caught
I would always expect my students to tap
because
if you get your leg broken or your arm
broken in the first round you still got
three more matches before you get to the
final there is a Escape Clause there is
if you're a guy from Ireland and you're
fighting the number one seed there is
always an escape Clause yeah like Let It
snap yeah Let It Go but um uh your
students yes yeah I I would expect them
to tap
um I also think that if you're in a
Stranglehold it doesn't make a lot of
sense and not tapping because you're
gonna pass out and
like it's like you said in cheers it's
kind of impolite to make the guy take it
through to its conclusion so um I don't
see any heroism and and just letting
yourself pass out
um now things change when you get into a
final
if you're in a final and you're hit on
points and
you're willing to
for most people at that point are going
to be willing to let something break in
order to win a gold medal
at that point I leave it up to the
student
it's a deeply personal decision I would
never say to a student I expect you to
let your body break in order to to win a
gold medal
um I think my students are more than
mature enough to make up their own minds
uh I would be angry if they let their
bodies break in a meaningless fashion in
some random tournament
um or in a first round match where
there's no way you could go on to to the
second third and fourth matches with it
with a broken limb
um but in a final in a gold medal match
in 80cc I would leave the decision to
them a spontaneous decision in the
moment I would be confident that I had
prepared them to do their very best to
defend themselves
um but what ultimately they do is their
decision and
winning ADCC is for a grip or at least
life-changing you're a world champion
forever and no one can ever take that
moment away from you so I would
I would understand if they took a
decision to take damage hopefully it
will never come to that because they do
a good job of Preparing People to get
out of situations as he saw with Gary
Turner who was in a dreadful situation
and got out within five seconds okay so
um uh Gary's been in arm locks that
looked like even I was in the corner
going like oh my God what is happening
here and still got out so uh it comes
down to training preparation but if they
did make that decision I would
understand provided it was a situation
that would make their lives better and
they made a calculation it's not an
emotional thing now sometimes you get
emotional you fight a guy you just don't
like and you just don't want to tap to
them
um
then things get a little more
interesting I then
again it's a personal decision if you
hate someone so much that you literally
can't even conceive of yourself
submitting to them
probably best you don't get into matches
with them in the first place
um but if it should happen
um again it comes down to the student I
teach technique not morals so I let
people make their own decisions on that
my thing is look don't get injured
because if you're injured you can't
train you can't train you can't get
better so stay away from injury as much
as you can
so one of the other incredible stories
here is as you mentioned Nicolas
murugali one of the
incredible ghee athletes and Jiu Jitsu
world
not ever having done gnocchi uh training
or competition and so on in a period of
a year actually is significantly less
than a year Nicholas only came about uh
six months I believe before 80cc as a
phone call came from Gordon he was just
like okay Nicholas wants to come down
and train he wants to move to Austin
yeah so he came down it was it was funny
I remember the first day Nicholas came
in
Nicholas virgali as you can see he's
like this tall handsome Brazilian guy
with a great personality and a wonderful
smile yeah also a super nice guy so he
comes in he sits down on the mat and
we're all kind of looking at the new guy
and
introducing ourselves and I look at him
I go buddy what the [ __ ] are you doing
here and he's like what do you mean and
I go like look at you you're like
tall and good looking you should be a
[ __ ] model not a juicy guy look at us
we're all [ __ ] up with horrible bodies
and bad personalities you're like a
you're like a happy good-looking guy you
should be surrounded by supermodels what
are you doing Jiu-Jitsu for and he just
laughed and he started um training with
us so um uh he came in now historically
he has been an athlete who always uh
pulled God this in in Jiu Jitsu parlance
for your viewers
um in in Jiu Jitsu you have the option
of sitting down to the ground you just
was mostly performed on the on the
ground you can and many athletes take
advantage of this ladies come out and
sit to the the ground position and
completely forego takedowns
um Nicholas did this his entire career
juditsu also has practiced both gee and
nogi Nicholas was a a Shining Light in
the ghee uh side of Jitsu he's one of
the great champions of his era but he
had not only never competed without a
gear he'd never even trained without a
ghee so
there's significant differences between
the two there's a lot of overlap but
there's also some very significant
differences
we're talking about a sport where even
small differences can make a difference
between a guy who gets the gold medal
versus the guy who loses his first match
um it doesn't take a lot so
this was a very very tall order a lot of
his attacks involve the ghee from guard
absolutely he's in a very dangerous way
I mean he doesn't just wear the geek he
really uses the key like his 90 of what
he's based around is based around a
combination of cross and straight collar
controls with with the control of the
sleeve cuff and so he really actively
uses the gate so when it came off his
first training decisions were like oh
this look like a fish out of water
um in addition he had no experience of
leg locking so one of the most
significant parts of the modern game he
just had nothing
um wrestling he had literally zero
wrestling which is half of 80cc is is
based around this so ADCC is like six
months away and he has to get ready for
the ghee World Championships he Nicholas
had won many accolades in GUI Jiu Jitsu
but he had never won the open weight
division of key worlds so he's like the
first day he's there he John I want to
be the first guy to win
ghee open weight and 80cc open weight
in the same year yeah
I'm like
I'm like um
yeah
uh now in my mind I'm thinking like yeah
that's never gonna [ __ ] happen you're
[ __ ] weirdo do you think there was a
degree to which he actually believed
that
is a degree
he thought it was like a certainty so
he's looking at me like yeah I'm gonna
do this so I'm like you know well
Nicholas this is uh this is very
laudable and and I I approve of your
confidence and
um but this is a difficult goal you set
yourself perhaps maybe like 2024 would
be a more realistic right he's like no
no I'm gonna do it in all seriousness it
is incredible that uh Nicholas murugali
had the guts that says such a nearly
impossible goal uh so what do you learn
from this experience of setting a goal
that most people would say it's just
unachievable and him actually almost
doing it it's on the surface just
absolutely crazy like when he's
mentioned the goal to me I was as I said
just looking at him and almost like
disbelief I didn't want to show it on my
face
um and yet he came within inches of
actually doing it he won his first ever
gold in the open weight with a ghee and
got to the finals uh and lost a tight
decision in the finals and to take a
silver medal he wanted two goals he got
a gold and a silver and there's a sense
in which the sheer audaciousness of of
the goal set
seemed ludicrous when it first happened
as they say this is this is insanity and
yet he came at it with a plan he came at
it with his characteristic passion and
hard work and came within inches of
doing so and there's a sense in which
you could look at it as oh he had a plan
and it failed
and yet of course no one in their right
mind would look at it that was he set on
audacious goal so high that it seemed
impossible and it pulled his entire
performance up to a level where even
failure creates something truly
memorable do you encourage athletes
or do you uh not get in their way when
they say such a goal maybe even just
forget athletes human nature yeah that's
a great question
um there's a sense in which you know you
don't want to make people delusional
that that's sad but I do believe that
if people are sufficiently
embedded in a given project if they're
committed to it to a certain degree
then you can skimp on many things in
life but don't skimp on your goals okay
because the bigger your goals the bigger
your achievements will be and even
failure as we saw in the case of
Nicholas merigali you I I I almost
frowned use the word failure because if
this is failure give give me more of it
you know falling slightly sure yeah
falling short of of um of what would
otherwise be a perfect year
um even that
still creates such a massive uh uptick
in your performance that it's absolutely
the right way to go but there is a
danger to this where people aren't
committed and simply aren't working from
a framework where they can realistically
achieve these things then it descends
into delusion and that that direction
goes towards Madness you can't have that
so there has to be
some kind of reality check here where
you have to be
uh uh physically and mentally capable to
some degree of moving towards these
goals you can't just you know uh a
random blue but can't make audacious
calls like that it's just ludicrous but
um
with with that in mind if if you're
committed and and you there's a sense in
which this is a definite possibility set
your goals high okay make big demands
yes there'll be times of frustration
there'll be more failure in your life
than otherwise but even your failures
will be something great something
memorable see but in the near term
you would be hard-pressed to find any
data that justifies that goal because in
his case he he probably wasn't very good
in nogi in the even in the training room
so it's like where do you look for even
inklings of hope uh we saw it in
incremental progress with each
successive competition that he was in
um his first competition uh uh he looked
good but not great second competition a
little better third competition took on
one of the legends of
uh American grappling and won decisively
so there was a sense in which it was
becoming more realistic with each outing
so now now putting that inspiring
philosophy aside what was the actual
plan on how to make it happen so the leg
locks thirsty with the same thing with
John Carla first you got to learn how to
defend a Lego up so
um
uh initially just as John Carlos
struggled he struggled uh then he had to
learn
not just takedowns but just how to set
up a teacher I had to learn Basics like
stance and motion and how to fight with
the hands etc etc so he had to learn
from the ground up and
um uh
then he had to improve he always had a
very good triangle always said very good
arm bar those were his two strengths
coming into the nogi training and those
translate pretty well between ghee and
nogi
um but he had no guillotine he he had no
uh strangles from the back where he has
great collar strangles on the back but
he really really struggled with
finishing people from the back so
um he's learning all this and then he's
like well now I've got to get ready for
the ghee so we had to switch his
training to ghee training and uh that
took out a couple of months then he got
he went back briefly to Brazil and got a
terrible rib injury right before the
world championships and came back like
more or less unable to move so the World
Championships is a week away and he he's
like John I can't move
yeah so I'm like what are you gonna do
so I'm going to compete
so I'm like are you sure so we fly to
California he goes out competes his
first opponent is literally the biggest
man who competes in jiu jitsu
this is this man is almost like 400
pounds yeah Nicholas has got completely
broken ribs we're taping up his ribs
backstage before he goes out to compete
he beats Everyone by submission
and wins for the first time the open
weight
um uh a title he had never won before
he steps off the mat looks at me goes
well I got the first of them he wanted
ghee open weight and now 80cc and now we
can barely move he's still gone through
two days of brutal competition and his
ribs are completely screwed up
it takes a week off to try and get his
ribs somewhere back in order and then
begins late training building up to 80cc
we start putting him in nogi competition
he
uh he fights two opponents of uh
good quality but not like World beating
quality and then
um as this game starts improving we're
getting closer and closer he's starting
to develop a sense where he can wrestle
confidently on his feet
is no longer easy to lay log at all and
is starting to leg lock people
and is starting to get his very strong
guard passing uh which was based mostly
around pant grips in the ghee to adapt
to
leg no gear grips
um in addition he's starting to develop
strong chest to chest positioning which
was never really part of his game a
pressure top game
and um uh so things are looking good
he's matched against Rafael Lovato one
of the great competitors of of ADCC and
wins a convincing Victory featuring a
lot of takedowns and a lot of pressure
passing and people were just absolutely
shocked I remember the staff of flow
grappling coming and going like
who is this guy he's like he's literally
transformed he's like a different person
so he goes into the World Championships
because in in his weight division he was
matched uh with a fellow Brazilian in
the first match and uh they had an
absolute Bond burning battle where at
one point necklace was picked up and
slammed and then ended up winning by
Kimura beautiful Kimura
um
then he took on the man who ultimately
wins 80cc open weight Division and
defeats him
uh matches yeah tough tough match now
Yuri samoy at that stage was two-time
gold medalist in 80cc Nicholas wins a
very very close match against him and
then fights Craig Jones who's one of the
best leg Lockers in in the in the world
so I think most people are expecting
Nicholas to get leglocked very easily by
Craig
um Nicholas showed the degree to which
he had improved his leg lock defense in
a six-month period Craig never really
got close to the legs and ended up
becoming a takedown battle could have
gone either way uh Craig I thought did a
really good job of of pacing himself he
both athletes were very tired but uh uh
Nicholas was ahead on points and then
Craig hit one last takedown which set
Nicholas down to a hip didn't score but
it was the most aggressive takedown of
that last period And so Nicholas got the
nod and won a narrow victory yeah Craig
commented uh afterwards he said that I I
really wanted the submission and he said
Nicholas seemed to have really wanted
the submission but it ended up being a
grueling match he took everything yeah
like uh exhaustion wise everything he
had it was it was a tough tough match
and um they were very well matched once
they figured out they couldn't submit
each other it came down to their their
wrestling ability neither one of them
was a wrestling specialist but they both
competent and and uh and wrestling and
um it became physically very very tough
um then Nicholas went on to win the
bronze medal in his weight division so
the next day when we get called for the
open weight obviously John Carter won a
gold medal uh the
um everyone agreed that he should go
into open weight and the John Carlo
agree
of course he was I mean like because he
didn't have an easy format you don't
order people into it you ask no no
I guess the question I'm asking is how
do you find the strength to then go on
to Absolute after
because you've done it
14-week training camp where every day
was just as intense as any 80cc day so
you're used to it at that point but he
had very very long tough matches but uh
he's used to it he's a good athlete
um so Nicholas and John Carlo went out
and um John Carlo had a spectacular
submission Victory against his first
opponent
um Nicholas had some uh some firework
matches and one of the toughest
opponents he came up against was the
brilliant Tai ruatolo they had an
absolute Barn burn it was a very very
close match and Ty had had an incredible
uh first two matches he'd beaten Pedro
Mourinho by submission and he'd beaten
the great Felipe Pena in a very narrow
magic very very tight Felipe lost on a
guard pole
um but Felipe is considerably bigger and
stronger than Thai so for Thai to to win
that match even by God Paul so deeply
impressive it was a it was an
action-packed match that went back and
forth very very impressed on a small
tangent yeah both of our tall Brothers
had an incredible performance uh what do
you think makes them so good if you were
to analyze their game sort of outside if
you enjoy this specifically absolutely
there's there's a range of factors one
is that they they started the sport very
very young active probably the first
example in American grappling of
American students who started at age
four or five most people when I began
jiu jitsu
started Jujitsu as adults I was 28 years
old when I've had my first lesson as a
white belt so
in time people got a little younger for
example Nikki Ryan started when I think
when he was 12 but
the rule told us started when they were
literally children they had excellent
coaching going all the way up through
into their teenage years
so they had the advantage of of starting
the way so many successful athletes do
as as children and going up through uh
adulthood and with strong coaching all
along the way excellent parental support
so they had like a great history where
they their youth didn't show off just
how long they'd been in the sport right
so you're dealing with a kid who's 19
years old but he's been grappling for 15
years yeah and uh what counts is not
your age but your met age yeah and
quality yeah now they were very young in
years but they were very old and mad age
and um but there's a lot of athletes
that have now as you've correctly said
have spent from a very early age on the
mat but still these particular ones
stand out it's interesting yeah no
there's a lot more to it than that this
is just the the first set in the scene
but what really makes them stand out
is that they've mastered this idea of
covering up and improving initial
weaknesses while building upon strengths
when the rotolers first encountered my
students they were relatively easy to
lay lock because none of their training
experience had prepared them for that
um
now they were they were young at that
time I believe like 16 or 17 and uh it
was an obvious problem for them they
both got peel hooked
um by male youngsters also
um Nikki Ryan and Ethan crownston and um
you could clearly see that they
identified
their current weakness and made
prodigious steps to improve upon it to a
point now where they're winning
championships with their own leg locks
like I love the fact that even as
teenagers they had the maturity to say
okay here's an obvious weakness let's
get around this let's turn it into a
strength
um I love the way they did that and
focusing on the weakness and let that
guide you to the thing you're working on
but they also that they they covered up
their weaknesses but they also
understood what are our actual strengths
now physically both of the brothers have
extraordinary reach for their height
they both have extraordinarily long arms
for their height
that means that variations of karakatama
in particular dasas anacondas are going
to be much easier for them in their way
division than for most people these are
all chokes yes strangleholds so they
specialize in those they adapted a game
based around movement
which forces opponents not with physical
pressure but with tactical pressure into
positions which expose them to those
specialized strangle holes that they use
um
traditionally when when we looked at the
ruatologist when they were young we saw
that there was a disparity between their
top game and their bottom game they were
generally much better in top position
than they were in bottom possession
again they saw that as a as a potential
weakness and they turned it around using
again their unique long limbs relative
to their height and they make use of a
buggy strangle I'm not sure why it's
referred to as a buggy strangle but it's
in it basically it's a variation of
karagatama using the legs done from
disadvantageous positions on bottom and
they both made brilliant use of that to
not so much as a strangle weapon
occasionally they'll strangle some of it
but they mostly use it to create
pressure to make people back off and as
a result they're able to uh they
overcame the disparity between their top
game and their bottom game now their
bottom game is part of their offense and
they're very very successful from there
and so again you hit that that really
impressive sense in which they
identified their weaknesses and leg
locks and bottom position turned it
around and made it into strengths and at
the same time they identified okay what
what are our physical gifts and how can
we maximize their use and they created a
program of initiating movement that
created tactical rather than physical
pressure to set up their best strangle
holds I'd deeply admire what they've
done there's two young men have a huge
future ahead of them and so here uh one
of the brothers faces in the in the
absolute Nicholas murugali and bear wine
Tai has just fought two very tough
matches against guys bigger and stronger
than himself so he's coming into a third
match against a third guy who's also
bigger than he is so uh hats off to tie
fighting open weight against three
monsters in a row
um now Tai and Kate one of their best
attributes is they are two of the best
scramblers in the sport of Jiu Jitsu so
whenever you go to shoot on the legs
with them there's a danger of running
straight into a dark Stranglehold
they're very competent at
counter-attacking single legs with dark
strangles
um it's also very hard to control them
after a takedown they do a very good job
of springing back up to the feet so I
told Nicholas to favor upper body Judo
bass takedowns rather than wrestling
takedowns and you see here a fine
example of Nicholas's Gathering skill in
uchimata one of the great throws of of
Judo set up with a
there's a bit of a foot and a foot sweep
like uh good
the nice thing is he starts off with
what it looks like it says actually a
two-directional ultramata he threatens
ochigari to the back that's a throw that
throws your opponent to the back his
opponent pushes into him that he changes
Direction with a support foot and takes
him over with uchimata now as we said
earlier the great advantage of Judo over
wrestling is that because this upper
body connection during the throw and
after the throw it's much harder for an
opponent to scramble away from you and
even Tai Rotolo is one of the best
scramblers in the sport
it has to stop scrambling here and just
uh go back to guard position and enable
Nicholas to to hold top position I mean
some of it is also the surprise there is
something less understandable about Judo
techniques because there's less data
it feels like the root holders also have
a good range I think they're very
familiar with it
how often do you think are they in the
receiving end of it that's a good point
yeah so I just feel like they have more
data in terms of Defending
um would I mean of course there is
fundamentals to the gemada that make it
difficult to scramble around but
this is a good example of someone who
literally didn't have a single takedown
six months ago now he's throwing one of
the toughest guys in the sport with one
of the more difficult throws of Judah
now you're a judo man yeah you'll back
me up it's not an easy throw to learn it
takes some time you're hopping on one
foot with both of your body weight
Supply
yeah it's a lot of the really uh it's
one of the more difficult throws let go
of your understanding of uh takedowns of
maybe wrestling style takedowns or more
intuitive kind of takedowns to
understand it there's many throws like
this which agaris like this uh sort of
guy is like this shimata is like this
it's weird what I'm on one foot I'm
hopping around this makes no sense yeah
but it works foot sweeps are also weird
in that way they're a little bit more
intuitive but like you get very good at
foot sweeps you have to understand
timing weight distribution there it's uh
it's a dynamic thing that's weird you
have to I always uh laugh and I talk to
Nicholas say you know
I try to teach them a single leg which
is traditionally most you know like a
high single leg is one of the easier
takedowns to perform in terms of
mechanical difficulty and uh Nicholas
always struggles with it and then I
teach him one of the more difficult
takedownsimata and he
does it flawlessly you never know
certain things get attached I mean you
see this in Judo it's kind of
interesting to see um
there's classes of takedowns and certain
people just gravitate
in their philosophical intuitive
understanding of body mechanics or
something like this it's like say Nagi
versus ichimada you very clearly see
there's some people that understand they
like to have both their feet planted on
the ground
and there's some people that are okay
with this one foot on the ground and the
other one is doing something else and I
think that I don't know what that
what is that I don't know it's what
makes you fall in love with one field
versus another
so what can you speak to that that you
know you've released a new instructional
on takedowns and standing skills for jiu
jitsu
just at a high level
using Nicholas as an example what are
some key ideas about takedowns
okay first whenever people talk about
standing position as you say they always
say oh I need to learn some takedowns
but
it's never a question of just learning
the takedowns it's learning the
prerequisites to the takedowns the
takedowns are more or less like an
afterthought
um
you've got to begin with stance
motion the ability to engage in grip and
contact get your opponent out of balance
and then comes the takedowns
um the takedowns in Jiu-Jitsu are mostly
divided into a lower body takedowns
tackles to the legs single legs Double
legs to a lesser degree high quality
and then upper body takedowns which are
mostly Judo derived
um
Nicholas had to start more or less at
the ground I didn't even know how to
come out and make groups or hold a
stance so he had to learn every element
of it and the fact he was able to do so
in six months is just incredible can you
comment on the
uh the upward posture that seems to work
for you just the matches in Jiu Jitsu
are much longer than the magazine
wrestling
um in addition there are many kinds of
submission threat which are not there in
wrestling so The Stance has to be
significantly changed in wrestling they
favor generally a very low Crouch
because the vast majority of attacks are
tackles to the legs so anyone who stands
upright and wrestling tends to get
heavily punished by being taken down
immediately with a leg tackle
um in Jiu Jitsu the matches are so much
longer it would be difficult in a
40-minute match for example to maintain
a bent over crowd should be exhausted
there's also problems associated with
submission holes there are many forms of
submission hold Guillotines tasks Etc
where if your head comes down too low
you become a little vulnerable to this
and so the the stances in uh Jiu Jitsu
competition tend to be much more upright
more like Judo and Greco so right off
the bat you see The Stance is different
the motion tends to be much slower and
more evenly paced because you've got to
be able to do this for long periods of
time so the the number of fakes per
minute the number of shots attempted to
per minute is usually much lower
um
so these are obvious differences
uh the biggest difference however has
nothing to do with that it has to do
with tactics in jiu jitsu
these scores
will be judged by what happens after the
takedown
in the case of ADCC
you can take someone down in ways that
would score in both wrestling and Judo
and possibly even win the match in the
case of Judah
and it would score zero in ADCC because
of the the nature of the rules
the whole idea of ADCC scoring is to
demonstrate control after the takedown
it's what happens in the critical three
seconds after the takedown that creates
the score in Judo and in wrestling
the emphasis is based on the takedown
itself in Jiu Jitsu the emphasis is
placed on the aftermath of the takedown
that's where the score is allocated
and that can be a period of up to three
seconds now three seconds doesn't sound
like much but in a scramble after I take
down three seconds is a [ __ ] eternity
it goes on forever and so you will see
many examples of takedowns that as I
said would score very well and and Judo
and wrestling but don't score at all on
80cc
and so the whole skill becomes packaging
the standing position in terms of the
takedowns themselves but in particular
preparing the athletes for that critical
three seconds after the takedown that's
why many people who have very fine
wrestlers struggle in ADCC they take
people down by wrestling metric all the
time but don't score under ADCC rules
what makes GSB so good at takedowns I've
got a chance to even recently watch them
do takedowns within this framework that
you you're teaching what stands out to
you about him that you draw lessons from
yeah that's uh another example of
someone who's performing takedowns in a
rule set radically different from
wrestling
um just as the ADCC rule set is so
different from conventional wrestling
rule sets that the whole manner in which
you approach takedowns and even your
understanding of takedowns has to be
quite strongly modified so to an MMA
it's even more extreme
um people always think oh this guy's a
good wrestler he should be able to get
takedowns in MMA easily
what you find is that the wrestling
skills in MMA enable you to finish
takedowns if you get in on your opponent
and get through the legs or the waist or
what have you your wrestling skill will
enable you to finish the takedown
but getting to the takedown is
massively different in the context of
MMA than it is in wrestling the entire
stance is different
foreign
distancing is different there's the idea
of positioning within a cage like how
close you are to the the perimeter of
the of the cage changes radically how
you approach the takedown
um the sit-ups are literally night and
day different it's the setups are almost
entirely comprised composed of striking
setups rather than grappling setups
and so the act of getting to the
takedown
is like a completely different sport now
George studied wrestling
and I used to go to wrestling practice
twice a week in Canada they do Freestyle
Wrestling they don't use the American
college style of wrestling now George's
main emphasis in wrestling training was
takedowns obviously the whole ground
element of of Freestyle Wrestling was no
interest to him like learning how to put
people's back on the ground and turn
them with leg laces and gut wrenches was
of no value in MMA so he devoted almost
all of his study to just the act of
taking someone down
um so as in pure wrestling George is not
bad
um uh I think he would be a very
competitive match even for a highly
ranked uh American freestyle wrestler if
she he would lose easily on the ground
because he's not used to the part here
he'd probably be legalized or gut wrench
quite easily by a skilled opponent but
in just a pure takedown battle he'd be a
competitive training partner for even a
good wrestler but in actual MMA
competition he could take down even the
most highly credentialed wrestlers and
in some cases it'll make it look almost
effortless
um and that
came from his unification of striking
skill with wrestling so he used
wrestling skills to finish the takedown
and his karate and uh boxing kickboxing
pedigree to enter into the takedown now
when he initiated the study of this this
was at a time when MMA was pretty much
in its infancy
and uh
uh he was one of the
most impressive people I've ever seen in
this regard he was a true innovator he
innovated this specialized area of
striking to a takedown to a greater
degree than anyone else I'm aware of
okay well let me ask you about this
Innovation because you're one of the
most Innovative people in in uh martial
arts
there's several major categories of
innovation that you have led
um obviously leg locks
body lock
now wrestling
what's your process of innovation so
seeing
the problems in a particular system the
the gaps
how do you identify them and how do you
figure out systems of how to fill those
gaps first thing I look for is
what are the current weaknesses in a
given
combat sport so in the case of
Jiu Jitsu it was very obvious that
historically Judas had always been weak
and leg locking Judas had always been
weak in a standing position overall and
um
these were things that needed to be
sorted out immediately and its infancy
mixed martial arts was divided between
Grapplers and strikeless Strikers and
uh most of the uh emphasis in early
mixed martial arts was on the idea of
specialists in a given domain forcing
the fight into their domain
and that
uh my early work with George Saint
Pierre convinced me that the right
approach wasn't increased specialization
and learning to force
uh your athlete into that area of
specialization at the expense of the
opponent but rather the the real battles
of the future would be won and lost not
worth
techniques per se specialized techniques
but rather the integration of techniques
and the overlap between the various
grappling and striking skills
so that someone who was an inferior uh
uh Grappler would have just enough
grappling skill to be able to hold a
Grappler off and then defeat them with
uh striking and a striker who was uh if
you've went to fight a someone who's
Superior to you and striking you would
have just enough striking skill to be
able to hold them at Bay and then enter
into grappling this went further and
further until it got clear that there
were whole areas of the sport that
needed you needed to change your entire
mindset about them
um
so that people went into
early MMA thinking in terms of Grappler
and Striker
um
what I started to think is in terms of
okay there are four fundamental skill
areas of mixed martial arts there is
shoot boxing which is the integration of
uh
takedowns and and striking there is
clinch boxing which is the integration
of upper body clinch skills combined
with striking there is fence boxing
which the two athletes are locked up
with each other on the fence
um uh and they have to integrate take
down take down defense and striking
skills and there is grapple boxing which
is the merging of ground grappling with
striking and when you broke MMA down
into those four categories you saw that
each one of those four domains
transcends
the specialized martial arts that form
their components so for example in in
clinch boxing you would incorporate
things from Judo Greco-Roman freestyle
Jujitsu submissions Muay Thai clinching
techniques
but
even if you took all five of those
the rule set that you're operating in
required such extensive modification
that the final product of clinch boxing
transcended all five of its component
martial arts and became its own
autonomous skill it needed to be worked
autonomously and when we broke
Georgia's training down into those four
areas that's when real progress started
to be made that's when you started to
see the integration of those four phases
and the Striking and grappling within
each of them
was where victory was being won and and
lost so once you reframe how you see a
particular combat sport
then you can start doing these detailed
development of ideas
that actually like they they fit there's
a sense in which that it had to start
with a paradigm shift and then a
research program began after that you
don't start with research you start with
the paradigm shift and then went to
research uh well let me ask you I got a
chance to hang out with you and Hanzo
Gracie at ADCC he keeps messaging me
saying he's gonna call me and not
calling me I think aside from being
hilarious charismatic and uh handsome
uh he is also uh and wise for his young
age
um he's also one of the greatest coaches
and athletes of all time in martial arts
so let me ask what have you learned
about life from Hansel Casey the degree
of difficulty
that henzo must have encountered he
never talked to us to us about it
because uh but I figured this out as the
years went by the degree of difficulties
he must have experienced when he first
came to Manhattan and started teaching
it must have just been incredible you've
got to remember henzo came from Brazil
training with
the best people in the world at that
time meaning Hixson uh
all the machados all of them were
located
around Gracie Baja and
um uh
that Rio Rio de Janeiro set they all
knew each other and they all trained
together they had internal problems of
course and but um they all knew each
other well and knew each other's games
so they all of them had beautiful and
highly developed Jiu-Jitsu so all hens
are new from childhood on was perfect
beautiful Jiu Jitsu and communicating
with other people who also knew perfect
beautiful jiu jitsu
then he comes to New York yeah where he
has to teach
in a language that he at that stage
barely spoke to a bunch of [ __ ]
morons who didn't even on my first day
in Jiu-Jitsu they had to explain to me
the difference between the mount and the
guard because as far as I was concerned
hey you're on top it's the same thing
yeah and they're like no no mountain is
different from God and I'm like no it's
not like you're on top of the guy you
just hit him so he has to argue with you
and imagine going from training with
Hicks and Gracie to having to tell some
[ __ ]
that God is different from Mount and we
was we were so primitive back then
it he went from the best training
culture in the world to literally the
worst just a bunch of
guys in their mid-20s who knew nothing
about the ground
just well luckily he's known for his
patience
but out of that he molded one of the
greatest gyms ever in New York yes uh he
had uh he did a fantastic job and most
of it was based around the idea that he
gave us complete Freedom we came in we
trained all day and I started teaching
beginner's classes
um and then some of his senior students
uh hikarua made a Rodrigo Gracie and
Matt Sarah opened their own schools
around the tri-state area so they left
there was a vacuum of teachers and he
asked me to start teaching
um uh I taught for for many many years
there and he always gave us complete
Freedom his only thing was to say okay
do whatever you want just make sure it's
effective prove to me it's effective and
that's the best research program you can
ever get you know show me proof and um
uh the
you know so many times especially in
those days in Jiu Jitsu there were so
many things that were just off limits
like you couldn't study Lagos you
couldn't do this you couldn't do that
like this kind of game was for cowards
this kind of this is the only kind of
game we accept and Enzo was never like
that he was just like okay just do what
you want prove to me it works and if you
give people
that simple structure you give them some
time some Ingenuity a lot of things can
happen I gotta ask you and by the way
he'll come on this podcast and I do feel
like it's a little bit like riding a
dragon or a bull of some kind it'll be
it'll be a fun Journey there's I can't
at least from my perspective
uh having interactive or having met him
it's hard not to smile
um for me he's easily one of the most
charismatic people in Jiu-Jitsu it's
kind of a fun to watch that humans can
be like this too it's just the the love
that radiation was is incredible I gotta
ask you this is from Reddit there's
there's a there's a few legends that
come from that gym but people on Reddit
kept asking me about some guy named
Boris
apparently you coached him and henzos
and he was a legend and he was
terrifyingly good uh What made him a
legend who's this Boris character uh
Boris is one of my early students one I
think he was either my first or second
black belt Boris came from Long Island
he was a wrestler he was a Russian
Jewish descent and highly intelligent
yeah and um now he was short of stature
but very
powerfully built and compact
um
uh very
nice polite young man
um but also slightly eccentric which uh
I always liked about him
um
he would always come dressed with
glasses on and he would leave the gym
uh dressed like to use the American
phrase a complete nerd with like his
pocket protector and any now he was
heavily muscled but he would dress in
such way that it didn't appear so when
he left and we always used to laugh like
you imagine some guy tried to mug as far
as they would see him with his with his
nerdy glasses on his pocket protector
and they would literally run into like
one of the most formidable human beings
in the entire New York area Boris
started training Jiu-Jitsu I believe in
Long Island and then
um when he got a tech job in Manhattan
started training with us in a morning
class now these were relatively early
days in Manhattan and my teaching career
and uh he and a group of others a very
small group used to train early in the
morning around 6 a.m before work and uh
Boris was a legend in those days now a
very young George Saint Pierre
came to
train with us at that time and he would
come in at 6am through his morning class
and uh he was one of the main training
partners for for uh Boris and um Boris
being arrested I used to generally
prefer top position and I would always
encourage George to play bottom position
I said you've got to get good and bottom
position you never know I know you're
good at takedowns but one day someone's
going to put you down so you've got to
work bottom position
um and Boris a very strong guard passing
I remember one of George's happiest days
is finally after like two years one day
he uh sweat bar it's got on top and
finished them and I remembered he was
that was one of his biggest uh uh
Thrills in all of uh his his training
career was the last time that ever
happened no Boris was uh he was a very
formal man for that time the funny thing
about Boris is uh every time we would
have a conversation he would say I'm
only going to do the sport until I'm 40
years old and then I'm going to stop
and I was like why like why not be like
a lifelong martial artist you know you
got so good you're good at you did so
you've got great skills you've worked
hard why not just keep going he's like
it's ridiculous for a man to train after
40. there's no need
and you can never give any reason for
this it was just ridiculous so one day
he now this is a guy who came in
literally every day
6 a.m every day
one day he comes in he comes up to be at
the end of training goes hey John I just
turned 40. so I won't be seeing you
again
and I thought that he's joking so I'm
like I'll see you tomorrow Boris he's
like no you want and walks off
how gangster is that and then he never
came back I've never seen borrow since
he came in was one of the best crappers
I ever saw
and just that's it buddy I'm out and um
so there's no one to walk away yeah
uh I also got to hang out got to meet
hang out with Ali Abdul Aziz he's a
hands of Gracie black belt fourth degree
Judo black belt and friend and manager
of khabib nuremov who's coming down uh
to Austin soon we'll do a podcast
hopefully you get on the mat and have
have a bit of
brainstorm
also he's a manager and friend of many
other amazing Fighters
um
I really love the guy uh the Loyalty The
the fact that he he looks for loyalty
and has that inner close Inner Circle
and uh integrity and character and
people I really liked my connected
really quickly but any any fun stories
about ali oh did you train together yeah
see he trained for many years in the uh
in the basement of my classes
um uh he's
his his story is one of the most
unlikely stories like if someone wrote a
movie plot about his life they'd be like
this it's absurd would be thrown out the
door in a second and yet it all happened
um uh
you're absolutely correct he his
from the unlikeliest possible starts
created a situation where he's I think
it's incontestable now to say he's the
most successful manager and mixed
martial arts history he has more
Champions under his care than than
anyone else I've I'm aware of and
respected and influential so I know on
all Dimensions yes now many people
aren't aware the fact that he was
actually a very good judo player he had
um judoka first yes yeah he had very
good uh nogi Judah
um he had an excellent uh haraikoshi uh
very good tanyatoshi
um and he through many people who were
highly credentialed wrestlers in back in
the basement back in the Glory Days of
MMA training
um he was a good example of a guy who
had very very good Judo hips and often
use it to to counter wrestling and uh
was a fine demonstrator of the idea that
when Judo was adapted to nogi gripping
it can provide a very effective foil to
many of the standard forms of wrestling
attack and he would often use uchimata
to counter leg tackles and do some very
very spectacular fashion well what do
you think about khabib
is there something uh from just watching
him or is there something you can
imagine uh if he comes down to the gym
that you might learn from the way he
moves the way he approaches wrestling oh
absolutely he's one of the greatest
combat athletes of all time if you can't
run for someone like that there's
something wrong with you so he
emphasizes control yes he does and he's
absolutely a master of exerting control
um
the amount of
grappling control he was able to put
over some of the most difficult people
in the world to control was truly
astounding he he beat people from every
cell he beat wrestlers he beat Jujitsu
players he beat kickboxers and he
controlled them all in more or less the
same way
um he has a very underrated bottom game
people think oh he's just about stifling
top control but people forget he was
taken down on several occasions and
ended up in bottom position and he
showed excellent guard work from bottom
um he was able to get into submission
holds readily on opponents from bottom
position he's got an excellent bottom
game
um
he people say oh he's just a positional
guy no he's not he's got great
submissions look at the application of
his triangle from both top and bottom
was Top Class he had a sharp harm log
from uh bottom position uh excellent
Kimura if you look at
um his Kimora finishes in MMA they were
technically very very well Set uh
excellent braking mechanics
um he's a very very fine Grappler in
both submission grappling and MMA
grappling I think we'd probably learn a
ton from uh from moving around with him
is it possible to learn
something about him or about hajja
Gracie or about Gordon by
watching them
or rolling around them for a little bit
so maybe hodger and and khabibas are
good examples
because they're able to do seemingly
very basic things
on everybody and dominate them with that
I think Gordon is as well but Gordon
seems to have more preference and range
of what he's able to do it's just it's
almost miraculous how much uh hodger can
do by just like the same exact thing on
everybody is that like uh is it possible
to understand why Hajj or khabib are so
good at very basic positions or do you
have to feel it or do you have to
or is it just something that's developed
over
I think I think for most people for the
vast majority of people it would have to
be explained to them
for a smaller group of people if they
felt it they could try to replicate it
and there are a few people who could
look at it and have enough knowledge and
say okay I can see what he's doing like
for example hodger could probably look
at video footage it could be grappling
and say okay I understand what he's
doing
um uh but the average person would
probably go over their heads you
sometimes think of like these great
athletes
like maybe they're too narrow like you
you might imagine they're kind of so
focused on a particular thing they don't
develop in interesting ways he's he's
just a sweetheart yeah he's a wonderful
person to be around
uh yeah he'll he'll he's also visit
visiting Austin but just I was so I mean
first of all I'm honored just uh
drinking a little bit too much in Vegas
with haja Gracie and just and talking
about uh
love and relationships and life and and
death and all those philosophical topics
as one does in Vegas
um and a little bit too much to drink
anyway
after ADCC was beautiful and on top of
that uh hanging out with Rogan many days
for UFC in the nadcc you know one thing
I don't know if you've gotten a chance
to hang out with with Joe when he plays
pool
foreign
I so I spent a lot of time with him when
he was playing pool like recently on
that trip to Vegas and there's something
Zen like about first of all just
watching him but I've never seen the
focus the guys got
on the game for hours
just deep focus unshakable focus that
was so interesting to watch that this
human being he's a celebrity he does all
kinds of stuff that he's able to to
allocate
as close to 100 of his mind as I can
imagine to a particular task and nothing
can distract him that was really
inspiring that you could still do that
on any task yeah Paul is a game of
physics that should be your domain oh it
is but that wasn't just physics yeah I
would think
you understand the game you understand
the physics of it
you also understand the the fun of it
because there's friends and laughter and
so on
I would be distracted by that a little
bit I wouldn't be as much he he
literally as the closer you get to the
table
the more it's everything Zooms in the
jokes there's funny things you can't get
his attention on anything it's that
Focus I don't know that stays that
really stuck stay with me that
like
uh you know those memes like
I I want to find somebody that looks at
me the way X looks at why I want to find
somebody that looks at me the way Joe
looks at a pool cue or whatever the
focus there I want to find something in
my life
rather I want to attain the level of
focus he has
for pool on a task that I care about
and that that Focus like [ __ ] everything
else
this is now it's time to do work
um I don't know that was really
inspiring I haven't seen that kind of
focus
um
for prolonged periods of times on a task
you should see some time the guy the guy
is I mean part of this just being
competitive with himself it's the hatred
of imperfection all those kinds of
elements but embodied in a singular
Focus we had no idea to even played pool
he should we should watch him he won't I
think it it could be one of his greatest
obsessions
like there's deep uh see I thought pool
is for like degenerates
like gamblers and like Hustlers right
like uh the same way I see poker
but like I saw like a wolf's slash like
Elite athlete in Joe I said I didn't
know this I don't know much about pool I
didn't know that you could have that
level of focus while still drunk out
your ass but extremely focused it was
beautiful to see I don't know inspiring
inspiring uh for me as a person who
highly values
a singular focus on a task let me ask
you from a perspective of a hobbyist
what major
practical changes can a hobbyist who
works regular nine-to-five job do to
improve their Jiu Jitsu so they're in a
gym
there's a lot of excellent gyms
throughout the United States what can
they
do to improve their Jiu Jitsu about
their about the way they think about
just about the way they approach their
actual schedule those kinds of things
that's a great question
okay
the less training time you've got the
more you want to maximize its effect so
a question becomes okay well if I'm
training say twice a week
and sometimes even once a week what can
I do to make sure that that
two hour period is used maximally
um
the less training time you've got the
more the onus is on you to have a plan
before you walk in the door
if you go in to saying
I'm Gonna Roll around and see what
happens or I'll just follow what the
instructor says
you'll get a certain amount out of each
class
but it will never be what it could have
been
go in with a plan
and enact it many people go in with a
plan and
don't follow it
let's say for example
we start with the program that goes like
this
first
try to create the most honest assessment
of yourself as a jiu jitsu player
it's tough to make an honest assessment
of yourself
because you never actually get to see
your game so what I would recommend is
to start by videotaping yourself
inspiring
with your peers
that's fascinating because we don't even
have that level of introspection ability
to reflect of what we actually look like
in grappling start with an assessment of
yourself and the most honest one comes
not from you comes from the camera
have a look at what you see
and start to say okay
many of the weaknesses
in your game are made much more apparent
by looking from the outside in rather
than feeling them during the heat of a
match
identify four or five of the biggest
weaknesses that you see
and start actively attacking those
weaknesses ask yourself let's say for
example
in the course of watching the videotape
of yourself You observe yourself losing
three triangles you attempted three
triangle strangleholds you failed all
three
you could start by saying okay
let me ask myself
who
are the people I look up to the most
with regards a triangle strangle who the
guys who have the best triangle
strangles out there
then ask yourselves
of those people who are the ones whose
body type and personality most closely
mirrors my own
and that would be a good example of
of taking a problem in your game
contrasting it with Elite level
performance of in people whose body type
roughly matches your own and then try to
take lessons you learn by observing the
best people and bringing them into your
own game in one specific area
as time goes by and you do this with
more and more elements of your game you
will undoubtedly improve
you will also have to make sure that you
take time during class to actively work
on these things
now sometimes in class you don't get a
choice the instructor sometimes says
okay today we're working this this and
this but there's always time after and
before class where you can do your own
drilling where you can make your own
inquiries and during sparring
there's no rigorous control over what
you do you can try to work the game into
the areas of focus so for example if you
want to work on front triangles it would
be wise for you to do most of your
sparring from bottom guard positions
that'll give you the most opportunity
um
uh and in this sense it always begins
with
an accurate assessment of your current
skill level you've got to start there
then I I always encourage people to use
video camera to make the most honest
honest appraisal you can yeah because
your own mind is not dishonest but it's
understandably inaccurate you tend to
feel things rather than see them when
you're performing jiu jitsu
then make a
a program for yourself based around what
you see as excellence
um
look at the people in the sport who's uh
in in the area you want to work on
people who are renowned for skill in
that area
if possible narrow it down to people who
have excellence in that area and their
body type corresponds with your own
and then try to take lessons learned
from observing the Excellence in these
Elite athletes and bring elements of
them into your game
never try to bring an elite athlete's
entire game to your game that will
create an inauthentic game on your part
which will always be a poor copy of what
you're trying to watch rather bring very
specific areas and skills that you see
and import them from different people
until eventually you find something for
yourself
experiment a lot okay
everyone's different and so you will
don't see the video research as the
final word see video research the way a
writer will see a muse
as some someone who initiates discussion
opens inquiries for your own research
the most powerful moments you will have
on the mat come from making discoveries
for yourself not being told what to do
not observing someone else doing
something but self-discoveries
those are the ones that will last inside
you so use video research not as the
definitive answer to your problems but
as initiating research for yourself on
the mat
and as time goes by and you do this more
and more often and more and more areas
of the sport I promise you you'll
improve yeah and I I guess when you have
the plan have a plan that carries across
many training sessions so I just
remember I know this is perhaps dumb but
I I saw in my own game early on a lot of
growth it's by self-identifying a
problem
and coming up by myself with the
solution by watching uh in that case
Marcel Garcia I just thought my
butterfly guard was very weak and so I
thought okay what's the solution here I
I thought maybe this escort thing double
X Card
okay so I watched a bunch of video let
me try to work on this and then all I
did just this is self but uh when I
could get time by myself meaning like
not instructor guided classes but in
training I would just
every everything I would put myself into
butterfly and ask card and then just let
go like don't progress sweep and figure
out a way to get swept to get right back
to it back to and everything it was
annoying probably to train with me
because that's all I did and that's all
I thought about I bet you learned
quickly yeah I learned it's the most
progress I've ever made now you could
say that xguard wasn't the right
solution for me that maybe that wasn't
the weakest point for me to work on if I
were to look back now it's still to this
day sadly the week the obvious weakest
point of for me is escapes from much
worse positions
that that should be worth them that
should have been worked on from the very
beginning yeah that's still today if I
were to say what's the weakest thing
that I should work on absolutely is even
um
even with one day a week
is escapes but yeah a lot of that has to
do with just uh
carrying like focusing on the one thing
over and over and over and over across
training sessions now it also um
I would write down on a sheet of paper
the number of times I would get an
x-card sweep
foreign
whatever it was like 500 sweeps a week
so I'll have to and then like the closer
you get to the end of the week the more
you like just pick up a small white 100
in a week yes your trading partners must
suck bro no no you start with with good
ones and then just get more and more
desperate start like finding the the kid
right that you can just sweep over and
over
um but like that number for me the
numbers for some reason were like set a
goal to pull off a technique
um it it enforced like we're staying
with this for a while this is a journey
we're doing and then for some reason for
me that helped me Focus the study
to understand the Deep complexities of
this thing that
um at least for me other people like
nobody at the gym was doing x-guard or
anything of that so you have to kind of
figure everything out yourself I'm sure
there's there's better ways to do that
but at least that Focus helps uh from a
hobbyist perspective uh what's the day
what's the perfect day in the life of
John donoher if we're talking about a
basic non-agcc
now your
uh I'm really grateful that you sit down
with me on a Sunday uh
late at night but it all starts again
for you tomorrow
so
three training sessions a day what uh
what time do you wake up
do you do like a mantra in the morning
uh do you listen to like uh some zen
music uh what do you eat in the morning
what what what's the perfect day look
like
um
when you say if it's a small animal yeah
to the gods
um I
usually uh
when you say a perfect day what I think
you really mean is an average day
perfectly productive average day yeah
um so as let's take Monday morning
for you uh watching this video we're
filming this later on a Sunday night so
um uh after this I'll drive home
um
we just had 80cc it was uh two weeks ago
it was one of the longest uh training
camps it was the longest training camp
I've ever run because of the fact we had
to go through three different matches
for Gordon Ryan leading up to it
um
so immediately after ADCC I cut the
training down for the competitive
athletes to uh one session per day for
the first week after ADCC to give their
bodies a bit of a break
um I still have to teach two classes in
addition to that to recreational classes
so my teaching schedule went down to
three classes per day
after uh one week
of relative break we go back to uh two
competition classes per day plus two
recreational classes plus an MMA class
four uh Gary tonan and his friends
um
the first class
requires me to get up around 6am
to drive I'm still a student driver so
I'm I'm not very good at driving so I
have to spend a little extra time to get
to the destination on time just just for
the record and John Paul pulled in a red
Lamborghini with a
um no you're the worst liar I've ever
met
um my day typically starts pretty early
I don't eat in the morning I just get up
and go to work and I teach through the
day
my last class finishes usually around 8
P.M
um during that time I
uh coach Jujitsu I try to find time for
uh one Instagram post per day which
usually describes some basic theme of
Jiu Jitsu in most cases unless we've
just had a competition in which case
I'll talk about upcoming competitions or
what happens after a competition but
most of them are just Express a simple
Jiu Jitsu theme
um I try to do a short workout for
myself
um
and uh uh then I go home at the end of
the day I always start by asking myself
what do my students need for me tomorrow
based on what I've seen today what do
the recreational students need and what
do the competitive students need this is
always done in the
light of um uh what are the upcoming
competitions
but throughout the day you're doing a
lot of really in-depth classes so how do
you either prepare for them or think
through them as they're happening think
through
the material that you're teaching I can
look at a class I've been doing this a
long time so I can just look at a class
and be like okay these guys need
distance and this and then I make
Reflections at the end of the day then
I'll take care of things that we all do
talk to family occasionally go out on uh
for dinner with friends
um
dates things like that yeah I had to
really harass you to drag you out
to hang out and it was very convincing
and food wise I eat once a day once a
day yeah at the end of the day I usually
stop off at a place like a supermarket
like Whole Foods or some equivalent to
that and buy something simple and eat
the internet wants to know the details
did you end up getting Wi-Fi for your
apartment no I'm still thinking about it
so yeah yeah I want to go to the pros
and cons
um there's no cons lots of Pros but I
just don't put much
importance to it things that are
unimportant I just ignore yeah there's a
lot of things in life that have a lot of
Pros but like they're lower in the
priority list why why because the 5G
already he's got it covered do you watch
much video do you watch video do you
watch footage uh video footage quite
often yeah I I especially things from uh
Freestyle Wrestling record Roman
Wrestling Judo
um uh and mixed martial arts also uh
subsidiary Sports to mix martial arts
like boxing uh Muay Thai and European
kickboxing just for long-term idea
Generations
yeah this is an interesting thing how
could this be incorporated in the
context in which we use it MMA or jiu
jitsu
as maybe it's immediately obvious or it
might become obvious in in a few weeks
or months
is there some aspect to um the way you
approach life and training and martial
arts that amends itself to minimalism it
seems like you live a pretty stoic life
or is that just the symptom of the
focusing you know my life wasn't always
like this remember I've gone through
different phases in my life I was a
university student and teacher at
University
um uh I was a nightclub bouncer for more
than a decade
um I've been through different areas of
life I've seen most things I've
experienced a lot I've traveled the
world
um uh at this point in my life people
think I live some kind of like monk-like
existence but um uh you know I I have a
private life I like to go out and have
fun like everyone else
um yeah I'm not like some kind of like
monk who just you know sits under a
waterfall and meditates for anything
crazy like that well that's that's what
I'm currently going through that stage
in my life the monk like existence so I
would be amiss not to ask you one of the
most important questions one can
possibly ask John donaher which is on
the topic of animal combat who wins
in a fight to the death
or maybe a uh in a sport competition
setting but let's go with a fight to the
death uh a grizzly bear
a Silverback Gorilla
and maybe a lion or tiger an African
lion or uh one of the flavors of tiger I
don't know who you think is more
ferocious what are the parameters to
consider here maybe I can throw a few
out and maybe you can give me
some thoughts about how much of these
parameters matter so first of all
intelligence
uh I do believe the gorilla is the most
intelligent I've did research for this
as you can imagine
[Laughter]
with Joe Rogan uh the uh the the expert
advisor to this very podcast on this
very topic is indeed Joe Rogan yes uh so
in captivity gorillas have been
documented to show complex emotions from
family bonds the ability to use tools
and to be able to reason about the past
and the future that's impressive so that
that's something that at least in
captivity the other animals have not
been able to do they already sound much
more advanced than I am
um
yeah so
that's intelligence then there is weight
I think that's something that you think
of at first uh the lion let's go with
the big ones that I took notes Here 550
pounds for big lion that's exceptionally
large like most male lines are around
450 pounds that's an exceptional Beast
then
thank you
um the the tiger can be larger than that
yeah much much larger
so we got the grizzly bear which is
probably the biggest of the bunch at uh
the large ones get to uh 1500 pounds
correct me some of this numbers I
believe most Grizzlies around a thousand
pounds big big beast I was looking up
the biggest but I didn't want to do the
biggest ever
I just wanted the big like the top of
the range because there's always the
range you can put it in at roughly
double that of even a very big lion
of course how that weight is used is
very important uh so there's also things
which I find is interesting as Anaconda
would just let me throw that in there
because there is 200 pounds what I
really like about that is it's not just
the way it's the form factor and I think
out of all of these the anacondas the
most
non-standard form factor which I totally
agree with that yeah it's like the the
uh the Knight on the chessboard it comes
in from a completely different angle so
we got that we got also uh
strength in which could be measured in
ability to carry stuff so this was
surprising to me I did look into this
carefully the grizzly bear at a thousand
or 1500 pounds can only carry at most
its body weight which is a lot
but a gorilla can carry 10 times his
body weight a gorilla can lift over 2
000 kilograms that's over 4 000 pounds
and gorillas themselves and adult male
weighs in around 350 to 400 400 pounds
yes that's so I like how in this
particular place where I found this to 2
000 kilograms is as heavy as 30 average
humans so gorillas
30 humans so that's carrying string and
then of course uh bite force because
that's one of the weapons in question
here so now this is really surprising to
me I the gorilla has worn me over
through this by the way uh intelligence
sucker for intelligence but the gorilla
bite force is the highest of all these
with 1300 PSI bear a second with 1200
PSI tiger is uh a third I think tiger
and Lions third with a thousand PSI
that's comparable and a bear is uh
anywhere from 900 to a thousand PSI
they're close but gorilla I would not
have expected now gorilla is not a
carnivore but apparently you chews it's
mostly it's grassy stuff right but it
like
it's difficult to explain why it has
such a powerful bite and it also of
course has very large in size of teeth
as well as chewing teeth so um also no
neck yeah
so because Nick begins at the top of his
head and this goes down to the shoulders
well a lot of the way they use their
teeth
all of these animals they the the
ultimate kill is to go for the neck the
bite in the neck I don't know exactly
why that is probably
has to do
why is that because it's a very strong
controlled position not just that it's a
is it the same as Jiu-Jitsu you think
because they get to also choke them out
it's very much in line with Jitsu like
lions are famous for using strangulation
as their primary method of killing they
they get a hold of the neck and hold
until
um the animal drops plus uh claws
I believe the tiger and the bear use
their claws and the lion too the lion
right and the lion uh
this is something that the gorilla
doesn't do
and uh Anaconda obviously doesn't yeah
so what what do you think how do we
think about this also there is uh I'm
just not letting you talk apparently
there's uh levels of aggression in terms
of these are also very important
considerations yeah what what is um all
the considerations you've raised are
very important and we we would have to
address them if we're going to go
through this topic
um first things first
whenever you go into a discussion of
this kind there's
a kind of natural impression that we all
have as to which one would be the most
formidable
um
and
it's important that you become rather
skeptical of your first intuitions
because they're often very misleading
just as every boy thinks his father is
the strongest man in the world
and then when he grows up into adulthood
he realizes
this father was not even close to being
the strongest man in the world it's not
because
of anything other than an experience to
a boy his father seemed overwhelmingly
strong he literally can't even imagine
anyone else being stronger than that so
naively he thinks his father is the
strongest man in the world so too in our
relationship with animals
when we look at a Silverback Gorilla it
just looks
overwhelmingly strong to us to agree we
just almost absurd like
um
you picture the greatest combat athletes
that Humanity has ever produced the
prime Mike Tyson Gordon Ryan for
grappling
they would literally be torn limb from
limb by an angry gorilla it wouldn't
even be remotely competitive and so
there's a sense in which we look at them
in awe because of what they could do to
us
but that can be very misleading and just
as a boy
looks at his father as like the Pinnacle
of strength you can't necessarily from a
position of inexperiencing weakness look
at a given animal and say oh that must
be the toughest animal in the animal
kingdom there's levels to this game and
um I think we can point out that the
gorilla ultimately would be pretty low
on those levels
pushback to this analysis because the
data we don't have much data on this we
don't have we actually have slightly
more than you think I believe oh boy
well it's anecdotal I feel like it's out
of context so these species don't use
this is not MMA they don't do
inter-species fighting often
yeah but there are some ways of looking
at this which can take this already
interesting question and make it a lot
more interesting
um
first we've seen that intuitions aren't
to be trusted so if intuitions aren't to
be trusted or what is to be trusted here
well I've always believed that there are
three
General
elements that determine
what level of success or failure anyone
will experience in combat and this is
true both for individuals and for groups
and even all the way out to Nations
um
the first is what are your skills the
second is what are your physical and
mental attributes so it's skills
attributes those are the two primary
ones and there's a third
which is your experience in using those
skills and attributes and real world
scenarios okay so whenever two we'll
start with two humans when two humans
get into a fight ask yourself what is
their skill set
what are their physical and mental
attributes and what is their experience
and using those in real world
applications and that will give you your
first
look at uh okay who's going to be the
more successful
um
then in addition to those
three General elements there's also four
more specific elements
what is the ability
of the combatants to initiate combat
because initiation is a big deal in
fighting the one who sees the enemy
first and can create Ambush conditions
or
initiate compact combat in an area or a
Terrain which is favorable to them this
is huge in determining the uh the
outcome of battles
second
not only is initiation important but
disengagement is important a lot of
battles don't go according to plan and
so your ability to disengage at will and
break off and away from a battle is key
to success so initiation and
disengagement are big
the third big element
what is your ability to end a fight
okay do you have an efficient method of
ending conflict
without that
the conflict could go on to a point
where you no longer have the ability to
uh to continue it if you have some
succinct method of finishing this is
huge in combat and determining winner or
loser so both from a winning and a
losing position so if you don't have one
there's a much higher chance you'll lose
but if you have an ability to finish an
opponent in the conflict uh reliably
this is very very important in
determining success or failure
and third is your ability to endure a
conflict longer than the person you're
you're engaged in okay so engaged with
sorry and so you get these four more
specific elements now do you have the
ability to initiate contact at will do
you have the ability to break contact
and disengage at will
do you have the ability to finish your
opponent efficiently and do you have the
ability to endure longer than your
opponent does if you have all four of
those
that's huge for for combat that probably
applies to human on human everything
military conflict everything even all
the way up to Nations
um
also ask yourself
what are the most efficient
methods of combat
across the globe across all species all
times
etc etc and you'll see that ultimately
they always come down to
three things
the first is concentration of force
okay one of the most successful
combat strategies of all time is the
ability to take
concentrated Force against the zone of
weakness in your opponent and if you can
do this
you will often break through to a point
of vulnerability attack that
vulnerability in a way where your
opponent cannot respond and cannot
recover from that vulnerable point being
broken do a high amount of damage with
Precision yes so this is one of the
great combat strategies in across the
animal kingdom across human history Etc
the second would be Ambush tactics
if you can Ambush an opponent with the
element of surprise this is huge for
success in combat they're almost all of
the truly successful Predators on this
planet are Ambush Predators
the ability to get off to a good start
in a way where opponents simply can't
recover is huge for combat are we
allowing ambush in our discussion
because humans would call this cheating
perhaps yes we would and
humans are pretty damn good at it too so
um uh and then the third is endurance
okay some uh
[Music]
species some people uh humans actually
are pretty good at this
um use endurance as a weapon and they
simply wear an opponent down over time
and break them and internationally this
can be done economically
um through numbers etc etc and uh and
you can destroy someone with just sheer
endurance yeah a lot of words throughout
human history has been Siege Warfare
yeah and so when you ask yourself okay
which one of these animals are going to
be the most successful in combat ask
yourself well there's these three
Elements which tend to determine
Successful Failure and warfare
um which animals exhibit these three
principles the best and we'll discuss
this but as far as um
uh generalities go uh whenever you ask a
question who will win between a and b
ask yourself
in terms of the light of what we've just
discussed
what is their skill set
what are their attributes both mental
and physical what is their experience in
utilizing these in real world situations
and then the four uh more technical
elements who gets to initiate contact
can you break off contact at any given
time uh what is your endurance can you
keep going
longer than your opponent does so a
skill set I wonder if a big component of
that of how much practice there is off
off the battle exactly so how much
quote-unquote you would probably call it
play
like play fighting let's start going
through our animals okay when you look
at the gorilla
you will see immediately that almost
every experience a gorilla has of combat
is theatrical
yes they don't engage in killing things
they scare rival males away in order to
gain ownership of females
but there is almost no
uh intra species death and those
conflicts they're almost entirely
theatrical they have for example
enormous
canine teeth but there is no record of
them ever being used in combat
um
they appear to be used purely for
intimidation purposes
there's a sense in which they have this
tremendous appearance and they have
tremendous potential they they really do
have freakish levels of strength
in in many different ways
and yet the actual track record of using
it is negligible it's not strange that
Evolution will develop such as it is
sewing machine like they're bite force
just makes no sense with regard to what
they actually eat I think well no I I
think that even the presence of canines
doesn't make a lot of sense they're not
going to use them what are they it comes
down to this idea their big thing is
intimidation so as a show you wanna
uh fake it and don't care if you ever
make it because fake is good enough
given that particular Dynamic now let's
contrast that with a male lion
's
take on the biggest meanest
toughest animals in the most competitive
killing War
on planet Earth which is Continental
Africa
um and they
literally just take I mean occasionally
they lose but
it's rare and they take out everything
just in order to eat they have to take
down wildebeest cape buffalo they they
keep Buffalo are incredibly dangerous
beasts just by themselves and yet Lions
regularly take them down
um occasionally large numbers of lines
will even swarm elephant and over 12
hour periods take down elephant on some
occasions this is all on videos it's not
just speculation so they just have a
level of combat experience which no
other animal
if I were to also project so the the
Eastern European style of wrestling
where they spend so many hours on the
map they really value the number of
hours on the mat at play from childhood
the Lions probably for my extensive
watching videos on YouTube they seem to
play with each other yeah for fun a lot
and I guess what even really helps you
see it you don't interact you don't play
with other gorillas you have
like you're more spending a lot more
time around
uh the opposite sex yeah so yeah I mean
even Lions uh when they they fight each
other the mortality rate when lions
fight each other male lions for
ownership of a pride
is very very high much much higher than
I believe any other species on Earth
um they're almost always fights to the
depth for the simple reason that when a
male lion loses control of the pride the
First Act the new lion does is to kill
the genetic offspring of the previous
male lion so when a lion fights another
male lion when one male lion fights
another it's not just a fight for his
own life it's a fight for his genetic
offspring and failure means not only
does he die
all his offspring dies and so when they
fight the implications are so deep it's
it's like a fight for your not just you
but your your DNA
um
most male lions have very short runs at
the top to get
killed or run off by by other Lions
um
now
this kind of harsh combat experience no
other animal can claim to have this
between what they kill to eat and what
they have to do to defend their their
stake and a pride
no other animal fights like that
um
they just bring a level of depth to
combat which is unmatched in the animal
kingdom they also have some other
elements too that they get to they get
the luxury because of their social
nature of taking more risks than other
animals like a tiger hunts alone so if
it gets injured it's a big problem it
can die if it's injured a lion can fight
uh cape buffalo get injured and be
covered by the other lions for food
until it recovers so it learns to take
risks and it's not afraid to go out and
fight very very hard whereas other
animals tend to shy away from risk
because they're solitary beers are
solitary that tigers are solitary so
they learned from an early age not to
take the big risk to go to a certain
level and stop if I could push back so
that's that's aggression and risk-taking
that's a plus for the lion but to defend
the gorilla because you said skill set
they are of all of those the only ones
that use tools have been shown to use
tools
we didn't say anything about weapons a
gorilla could in theory pick up a rock
and it does have the like the force the
power and the capabilities to do a lot
of damage so it doesn't have the
practice it doesn't have the experience
but don't you think
if if a gorilla's back is to the wall so
you put them in a situation of it is
life and death
for both The Lion and the gorilla don't
you don't you value intelligence at
least a little bit here there's a reason
why humans this is like evidence that
you know humans have spread all across
the world while being kind of weak
why okay intelligence is a huge huge
asset humanity is positive proof that it
is the most important asset but it takes
time in order to
work is Magic it took humans
200 000 years to go from the bottom of
the food chain to the top of the food
chain
um and gorillas have a lot of work to do
before they get to that level uh humans
can use it you said in theory gorillas
could do this but let's talk about
practice now first off there are many
documented incidents of leopards killing
gorillas
that's that's anecdotal evidence no it's
not there's a bunch of bitch-ass
gorillas walking around we know this
we're asking not anecdotal it was
observed by a group of people who
specialized in in observing gorillas
over a 12-year period they regularly
found gorilla toes in lipidification
um they also saw that over a certain
period some 36 gorillas have been killed
and evidence strongly suggested leopard
predation was the reason apparently the
leopards had figured out that there is a
femoral artery
and gorilla's legs and we're doing a
move which from the sounds of it sounds
a lot like a baron bolo where they were
spinning underneath gorillas and biting
the femoral artery and then disengaging
and watching them bleed out and die and
then eating them now a leopard
is no match for a lion it the only
defense it has to align is to run up a
tree it cannot engage with a lion on
anything close to equal terms it may
seem like we're going out of tangents
but we're not just because of the foot
the attack of the artery and the foot
is there weaknesses that the lion might
have of that what I'm saying is I I know
it's not equivalent but the the fact
that a leopard does so well against even
fully grown male gorillas
makes you should make you rather
suspicious of a gorilla's ability to
fight a lion
fair enough let's also go further into
this let's talk about concentration of
force
the lion has the quintessential
concentration of force which is fangs
and claws
the gorilla is the exact opposite it
can't even make a fist
and so it can only throw open-handed
slaps and grab things so it it has no
ability with its with its arms to
concentrate force in any kind of
efficient way when a lion or a tiger
swear or a bear for that matter swings
at you it's got four Claws from four to
six inches long it's like four blades
going into you they can retract their
claws so they're always sharp but the
reach is significantly longer for the
gorilla the length of the the ability to
engage with speed on the part of the the
cats is is far far greater and also
mobility and to feed the bipedal nature
of a gorilla the the the temporary
Barbados this is the bear has the same
no impact humans will bipedal and lions
kill 240 humans a year on average
hmm
so okay okay okay what about bear no
because there beer is a difference for
all the same things that a lion has
the claws the teeth yeah has more weight
it has more strength has more power
okay now this is an interesting question
okay you get a fully grown North
American Grizzly this is an African lion
this is an interesting fact I also have
questions about polar bears it's unclear
to me because they're big they're bigger
in every way than than a Grizzly yes but
they probably don't get the experience
in the practice yeah also they have a
much more limited set of uh animals that
they've they Prey Upon so I'm pretty
sure Grizzly is going to be tough to
beat as far as Top beer goes
um
a grizzly bear
I believe would be a formidable
adversary even for a for a male lion
um they're literally twice their size
they have an ability to get away from
strangleholds by standing up on two legs
so the Lion's primary method of killing
which is the strangle would be very
difficult for them to employ upon a bear
um
interestingly the Bear's primary method
of killing is to pin it pins animals and
then just slowly eats them while they're
still alive they have a rather barbaric
means of killing lions are much more
Humane in the way they kill
um
I what I see is the primary problem is
that neither one would ever be able to
kill the other uh that finishing thing
yeah they both fail on the finishing
criteria
the lion would not be able to strangle a
bear even in the best case scenario
where he got his teeth into the neck the
bear can stand up and and presumably
Shake him off
um uh the uh the the the the bear would
never be able to pin a line for long
enough to better hold it down and and
slowly Maul it over time the way it can
with an elk or a caribou so I don't
believe either would be able to finish
the other they'll just become exhausted
it would be it would come down to
endurance now that's where things get
interesting because the bear is much
more of an endurance Hunter and the line
is much more of an ambush Hunter
lines quick explosive much higher top
speed they've got a top speed of 45 to
50 miles an hour a beer can do up to 35
but it can run for long periods at up to
25 miles an hour very long periods
they're mostly a uh an endurance Hunter
they just run
uh elk and moose down until they're
exhausted and then pin them and kill
them so if it came down to endurance
might go the way of the beer if there
were if they were caged up together
however there is very strong evidence
from both hunters and video
which shows on many occasions beer is
being chased off by
cougar
and Wolverines
now what's that that's fear what is that
what do you mean chased off uh if they
fight over uh uh meat which uh and say
for example a cougar has killed
something and the bear wants the meat
the cougar will come there risk aversion
exactly exactly the Bears are risk
averse what I would say is this the
beers are very very powerful in their
domain but they don't have the battle
experience of a lion they don't take on
animals as tough as a cape buffalo they
don't take on elephant what the toughest
thing it would probably take on would
probably be a a bull moose and uh a bull
moose is a formidable animal but it's
nothing like a cape buffalo it's nothing
like an elephant an elephant or a
hippopotamus
so what I would suggest is this
in the wild I don't believe either one
is capable of killing the other but I do
believe based on video evidence of
cougars and Wolverines chasing off beers
that a lion would provide
enough threat
in a brief fight that a bear would back
away if you put them in a cage however
where neither one could back away I
would slightly favor the bear
based on the fact that it neither one
can kill each other would come down to
endurance you mean like an octagon yeah
that's got to be the next UFC by the way
beer versus
things change Joe Rogan's a big fan of
the idea of fighting in a stadium for
humans fighting in a stadium hmm
um so in the stadium of bear I would I
would slightly favor beer now I still
think that the lion would have a chance
but I would favor the Bear in a betting
match
um some of the best evidence we have for
animal versus animal fights come from
the ancient Romans who actually used to
put animals in gladiatorial combat and
um
they for example had several incidents
where they wrote about tiger vs lion
uh conflict and uh in one famous passage
they described a lion
getting destroyed by a a female tiger
um so there's there's some evidence to
suggest that they had more expertise of
this than we do because they had a big
population of wild animals which they
just put to fight each other
um unfortunately there's nothing that
they wrote about beers versus lion they
did talk about uh bears versus bulls uh
they did talk about Lions versus Tigers
um but they never mentioned bear vs lion
so we don't have any evidence for that
so we have to be a little bit more
speculative now given that bears do get
chased off by cougar and cougar is weak
compared with a male lion they'll listen
to you draw from that by the way I would
suggest that is it about the Bears yeah
it's more about the bear like in theory
a bear should be able to crush a cougar
but it seems to be the beer is a scene
uh this thing could hurt me so I'm not
gonna risk injury and backs away I think
it would back away in the wild from a
lion but put him in a cage and I
slightly favor them the grizzly based on
endurance
so the final conclusion
if you had to just bet everything you
own so you got uh let's say we got the
Octagon we bring in a bear
now this is like legendary bear okay
full grown Grizzly full grown Grizzly
but not only that that Grizzly is seeing
some [ __ ] what's the most it could have
seen a bull moose
a caribou that's the toughest opponent
has ever had it once no no no no now
this one once ran into a pack of other
Grizzlies and had to find defend and
he's got heck of Grizzlies there's a
pack of Grizzlies they're solitary
wolves wolves wolves what was a good
practice for a bear who attacks a bear
that's that's my point Bears don't
really live in a competitive environment
lines but sometimes it can get desperate
as it was a pack of wolves but that pack
of wolves is nothing that that's nothing
all right fine Lions deal with packs of
hyenas okay what was the just imagine
over the past hundred years what do you
think is the hardest fight
that a grizzly bear has been in like
somewhere in Alaska we never heard all
of a sudden in the middle of the night
all you hear is the bear just they
didn't really there's nothing that
that's gotta have been something humans
have killed they run away from cougars
and Wolverines like no that's anecdotal
evidence there's got to be one bear
there's video footage of it you can
watch it yes they're called anecdotal
evidence there's got I guarantee you in
the dark of the night there was an epic
battle of which there's still Legend
amongst the Bears in that part of Canada
who did it battle in Canada moose on the
Bears you don't think they'd go at it
they have bears fight each other but
it's largely theatrical they never kill
each other when lions fight each other
they kill each other all the time
like that someone would have seen it by
now interesting all right so so you're
seeing my point is that Biz it just they
they they they want to get their feet
wet they're giving no credit for
gorillas so you're saying lion wins your
money's online no I'm saying lion would
win in the wild because they they can't
kill each other they can't end the fight
that's one of our most important
criteria
um but Lions can almost always initiate
the action because they have much better
uh uh ability to see at night for
example Bears have very average night
vision Lions have superb night vision so
at night time they can always initiate
the fight lions are natural Ambush
Predators so it's always going to be
able to have the advantage of Ambush
um the great advantage that bears have
is endurance uh but bears are very
risk-averse and they're not used to
fighting like the toughest toughest
animals the toughest animal they fight
is a moose or a caribou these are not
not even close to the animals that Lions
have to go up against on a regular basis
so if somebody wins it's going to be the
lion for you I still think that the size
and endurance of the bear if they were
locked in a cage together I would still
favor the beer under those circumstances
but in the wild I believe the beer will
back away in the cage no time limit you
fear for the bear what if it's five
rounds or five minutes Championship I
think then I would go with a lion
because the lion has a huge speed
Advantage so it's gonna it's gonna
injure it tear it up and uh and do
immediate damage like I put it this way
if lion and bear fight first 15 minutes
I favor the line 100 but then as time
goes by that size and weight is gonna
and endurance is going to have an effect
I'll bring up shortly somebody that's
going to probably disagree with you
about some things hopefully it's a
grizzly bear and it comes and just eats
me
oh that would be so epic
um make a hell of a podcast I wonder who
you would eat first who would look
scarier more delicious I'm not sure the
black and white could either piss him
off he would think you were a penguin
is that a good thing or not no good if
it was a polar bear maybe it's different
um
deeply about your uh about athletes you
coached about people in your life
so I have to ask this question
if one of those athletes let's say
Gordon Ryan
I was the dictator of the world and this
would entertain me so I force you and
Gordon to do this uh to fight a bear or
a lion Gordon has to uh how would you
coach him to do it
uh to have any chance of winning
he goes in empty hand empty-handed you
can choose Stadium or
um cage
Gordon Ryan empty-handed versus a lion
you get to choose lion versus bear it's
up to you okay my advice would be very
simple yeah I would say Gordon you're
[ __ ]
you're going to die badly
choose the lion because it will strangle
you to death rather than pin you down
and Maul you to death
didn't we just talk about audacious
goals
this is not a question of audacious gold
this is a question of minimizing pain so
you coach your athletes to quit before
the battle has been fought 100 yeah
how what's he gonna do you don't think
there's a technic first of all
intelligence so technically you gotta do
a heel hook no no well first of all
maybe you can't do a Double A's or four
[ __ ] legs okay what if Gordon gets
any starting position he wants oh yeah
that's gonna be really useful
on a thousand pound beer yeah
[Music]
shaken off he'll get torn off with what
like the reaches back he's got four or
six inches oh he can't get I wonder what
is the reach whatever he touches he's
got if it's not a flexible bear
so you think there's no control what
about like a low like a uh some kind of
controlling position from yeah like you
said purple like from underneath nothing
this discussion is so insane I didn't
even know where to begin criticism I
don't think you're open-minded we could
we could turn this down forget about
Gordon fighting a a lion or a bear
that's that's completely impossible an
adult male chimp will destroy Gordon
it's not even a gorilla
is more than enough to kill any human on
the planet including Gordon Ryan so
Gordon Ryan fighting a chimp a good
sized no a thousand times how many times
does he win he loses a thousand times
it's not even competitive it's not even
remotely compared do you think he will
disagree
no
do you think anyone will disagree anyone
yeah [ __ ]
okay uh somebody that I think you might
know uh there's a famous actor Tom Hardy
but he's also doing uh quite a bit of
Jiu Jitsu the reason this makes sense to
bring up now is he's also I saw
narrating a new Sky original series
called Predators coming out in December
where they follow five different
predators and tell their full story
about all the fighting The Killing and
all that kind of stuff and he's doing
that he's like it's like Morgan's uh
it's like Morgan Freeman from March of
the Penguins it's Tom Hardy for for the
Predators uh so I don't I saw a bear and
a lion in the it's in the trailer but
they also had something I didn't watch
it too careful but they had something
like a hyena so they think they were
talking about I don't know if it's a
hyena but something like that like pack
animals yeah that attack in Chinese have
formidable formidable animals so it's
not all about size it's about like
strategy you know the most important
thing in nature is numbers like uh you
know a pack of animals will always
destroy a single animal and I think that
show in particular is not 100 about who
wins or so on it's about the fascinating
stories of how these Predators sort of
dominate that particular environment
because it's it's not about these like
artificial matchups it's about giving
your environment how do you succeed and
all that kind of stuff maybe we could do
golden Ryan versus a house cat
the Gordon might have a a small chance
against the house cat maybe maybe
see now I know you're just trolling me I
I think Gordon has a chance against uh
well definitely against
the smaller Apes
but I have no way of proving it and and
the internet will say I'm an idiot so
there you go the internet is correct
every so often so there's a oh it's
funny enough I'm looking at uh Tom's
Instagram he has a picture with Hanzo
he's competed recently which is very
cool in Jiu Jitsu that's awesome that's
tough to do for a celebrity to step up
oh yeah absolutely yeah
um he he used to um consult with me a
little bit on um uh moose when he was
starting out he's a very very nice
person oh boy yeah yeah you ask
questions about Judson he struck me as
being a very very nice person I would
love to be a fly in that wall but he uh
he made a post on Instagram which I'd
love to get your opinion on it has very
much like a John Donahoe style of
digging into the philosophy of the
impact of Jiu Jitsu on one's life
is this Instagram post 18 pages long yes
he's got potential then yes with a
profound deep picture of somebody
practicing the art of Jitsu I think I
think uh I think he's at least a trainee
in this art of the Donna her style of
communication if Miyamoto Musashi would
be alive today he'll probably be doing
these five page Instagram posts like you
do
addiction writes Tom Hardy addiction is
difficult and complex stuff to navigate
as is mental health subjects which are
both deeply personal for me and
extremely close to my heart it is an
honor to be able to represent the
charity and my team reorg and the great
work they do supporting the mental
health and well-being of veterans of
service military and First Responders
through the therapeutic benefits of Jiu
Jitsu and Fitness training he
represented them in this competition
that he competed in simple training for
me as a hobby and a private love has
been fundamentally key to further
develop a deeper sense of inner
resilience calm and well-being I can't
stress the importance it has had and the
impact of my life and my fellow
teammates and he goes on to talk about
this organization re-org that uses
Brazilian Jiu Jitsu to form a therapy to
overcome physical and mental challenges
strengthen social connections and
improve overall health and well-being
this is for Veterans for people going
through PTSD
they have saved lives around the world
by not only providing an effective and
positive means for navigating and
managing the challenging psychological
aspects of military and first respondent
careers but also has allowed many to
find a renewed sense of purpose identity
and Community that's often lost when
transitioning to civilian life do you
have thoughts about that sort of the
effects of Jiu Jitsu on
on on folks who've gone through some
really difficult yeah things in their
life
first off I think that's just a
beautiful statement by by Mr hardy
that's uh I must uh
give them a phone call after this and
talk to him it was beautiful to read
um
one thing that's always struck me when
um I train people who either have a
military background or on more than a
few occasions
um we have special forces soldiers come
in and train with us for a week or two
and
when you talk to them
the overwhelming sentiment I get
when the conversation is over and we go
our separate ways is I'm always asking
myself
the transition from military life
especially the more extreme military
lives of Special Force Special Forces
soldiers
back to civilian life it must be
the craziest experience of all
you've got people who
of fighting and dying alongside their
their comrades
in the most extreme circumstances that
any human being can go through
and then they're pulled back into a life
where
people are arguing with them over
parking spots just like the average
person's
day-to-day life is so mundane
that imagine what must be going through
a man's head
who a few weeks or months ago was
literally fighting for his life and his
comrades lives watching people that he
loved die or get mutilated in front of
them
things that
you know in a matter of seconds people's
lives can be torn apart and changed
forever and then suddenly you get thrown
into a life where people are arguing
over
you know who's who's cut who off who are
in line to buy a coffee the intensity of
camaraderie and love the uh for each
other and then you go from incredible
intensity and War to
just mundane boring life and going from
one to the other where people are
yelling at you or nagging you over
issues that just seem so inconsequential
compared to what you've been through
and you're supposed to take these people
seriously and listen to them but not
like that you do have trauma visions of
dead brothers and sisters and you feel
like you can't really talk to these
civilians about it there's nothing in
their experience that would enable you
to have a conversation with them like
they they don't even how do you talk to
your new girlfriend about you know
watching one of your friends legs get
taken off like there's no conversation
you could have with them
um
so I find that typically
um
they do best when they hang out with
each other because they have shared
experience they can talk about these
things
um
but I do find that
most Jiu Jitsu schools have something
like a kind of military barracks
demeanor to them of like camaraderie
hard work shared hard work
um
teamwork
uh uh building towards a goal over time
the acquisition of skills usually along
with that a kind of
want of a better word or rustic and
primitive sense of humor and and
um a kind of soldiery way of talking to
each other and disparaging you know
self-deprecating sense of humor and it's
something that most people with military
service kind of
naturally come into because it's part of
what they were in and so it's like a
toned down version of it which enables
them to form a stepping stone between
the uh the military life that they were
in
all the way down to civilian life and
Jiu Jitsu is kind of like a bridge
between those two and also the honesty
so you said like the skill acquisition
the honesty of really testing that skill
there is a deep honesty to war in in
this in a distant way
but in a way there's an honesty to Jitsu
deals with technique working and not and
there's a final there is simulated death
it's not real death it's simulated death
on the mat yeah and there's a similar
kind of honesty there and there's also a
similar kind of esteem towards skill
um just as regular soldiers look up to
Special Forces soldiers because they see
them as people have
you know greatest skill than themselves
something to Aspire to so too and and
you just like the thing that we esteem
most on an agility matter skill no one
gets a damn what you look like or what
you think that you you judge mostly by
your skill level and
um uh and so they tend to identify with
that I do think that um uh most people
from a military background kind of find
a natural gravitation towards the the
atmosphere of Jiu-Jitsu learning and if
it proves to be a a positive way for
them to to rehabilitate and come back
into civilian lives and that's a
wonderful wonderful thing I know we're
linked with uh we defy which is a an
organization which caters to
former soldiers who were badly injured
in combat and many of whom lost limbs
and
or suffered mental trauma and they come
in and train and they often speak very
very highly of their degree to which
Jujitsu has helped them come back into
civilian life and and for them it's even
worse because they come back not only
mentally
but physically disadvantaged after war
and
um uh and I've always been proud to be
associated with we defy and I'm very
happy to see Tom working with this
organization is this an organization
based in England for English veterans or
is it International it's a good question
I'd have to look into it it certainly is
based uh uh in England but it could be
International
but it's just nice to see somebody use
that large platform yeah and also to
step on the
on the mat and show the kind of Jiu
Jitsu you would probably be proud of
chasing submissions you got he got an
arm lock he got a straight foot lock
we're not going to analyze the
techniques because you know that could
be uh it doesn't matter different
perspectives it finishes the Finish yeah
no that's impressive
um he's actually quite an athlete he's
uh he's in great shape and um uh strong
and flexible and I'm glad he's doing
well with his Jujitsu it's good to see
henzo's smiling face next to him I can
only imagine the conversations I have to
ask you a uh
uh deep and important question you often
when we text back and forth send me two
hugging emojis
uh can we psychoanalyze the reason why
that's your favorite emoji
of the hugging face is that it's it's
like it's kind of like sending a heart
but like a little bit more yeah it's uh
gender neutral
when Jujitsu plays uh meet each other
they often shake hands and then give a
quick hug so I thought it was the most
appropriate Emoji for Judas who plays
I see so it's a pretty simple
explanation nothing too Freudian there
are you sure
quite sure okay have you really asked
yourself deeply because you're really
lean on an emoji is there something
behind it tomorrow I'm never getting why
is that emoji again
walk away I'll shock you tomorrow and
hit you with three
three it's almost always two
I think maybe your creature of habit in
communication there's a I'm a creature
of Heaven in almost every aspect of my
life so even emojis
yeah you fall into these little pockets
of how you communicate how you show
affection towards others I sent I say
love a lot I sent I send hearts and
don't give a [ __ ] if it's too like
you know like in a you know me sending a
message to like a CEO I'm about to
interview I'll send a heart I don't give
a damn
they'll probably just like look uh what
is this but uh I think people are
two
afraid of simple
communication of affection
like uh it could be in any form but
there's a hesitance to that because I
think underneath it in order to show
affection
you're taking a risk and you're showing
vulnerability
because if you show affection and the
other person rejects that affection
you've now placed yourself in a
hierarchies going back to Lions of like
oh this person you're just like the
silly weak person and they're the strong
person I think that's called you might
see it I guess but I I don't to me the
display of vulnerability is a display of
strength
not uh not weakness at least in human
society at least at this time
I don't know uh let me ask you about
love
uh you know I must ask John honor about
love what do you think is the role of
Love In The Human Condition at the
highest philosophical level let me first
ask what's
um
like romantic love romantic love let's
say romantic love I have one or two
areas of apparent expertise in my life
romantic love
definitely not one of them so like lions
versus Bears I'm good animal combat I'm
good pretty good at and then different
grappling Arts Judo [ __ ] jiu jitsu
uh wrestling uh for MMA so fighting and
so on romantic love you don't see them
as similar it's a kind of fight
it's a kind of dance by the way
there's a sense in which I'm kind of
glad I'm not an expert on that imagine
what it would be
to be an expert on romantic love you
would take the one thing in life that's
actually interesting and make it boring
because you've
once you develop an expertise about
something you can start to predict how
things are going to unfold you get
answers before events even occur you see
you can read into the future of
everything I think there are certain
parts of human life where you want to be
a beginner at all times and you don't
want to gain expertise so excellence and
systematizing something in order to
achieve Excellence might destroy the
very yeah and I think that the the magic
of a romantic love is the fact that
we're all beginners at it and the minute
you try to gain expertise in it
what does that even mean like what would
it mean to it would be good I didn't
think it would I think you're better off
just
having fun with it and plowing through
and making dumb mistakes and looking
like a fool and
um uh and then whatever
success whatever that means comes in a
kind of light-hearted frivolous kind of
way and
um and that I think is
over the course of a lifetime far more
desirable than having you know expertise
and and Affairs of love so I don't think
it's even a good thing to study too much
and I think if you did you would
actually take something good out of your
life
yeah there's there's communities that
people call pickup artists that try to
optimize
this particular aspect which is of
dating of of guys picking up girls and
turning that into a system and seeing
what's the most successful I think that
would be
I mean maybe the first few months would
be good and then after that I think it
would be a disaster
um uh I mean
given that
humans have to feel easy to study from a
from the standpoint of psychology I'm
sure it's not that difficult to gain
expertise and
things like picking people up the same
way advertisers can pick up your
attention to sell a product you can do
the same thing presumably with romance
and sex but
I don't know I feel like
if if you became very good at it
you would end up being very disappointed
by the results and
um so as I said I think there's there's
some things in life where it's better to
be a beginner and this is one of those
yeah enjoy the chaos the push and pull
the beginner and make that a lifelong
journey that's really inspiring to hear
you say that and there's a deep truth to
that that also justifies the fact that I
suck at it
um I think it also justifies and it
would sell very well that John Donner I
should write a book on dating and that
would be chapter one Embrace being a
beginner chapter two will be bear versus
lion
pivot quickly to Violence by the way we
totally skipped over Anaconda
I I assumed the implied
I'll I'll put it to this way
on video you can watch Puma yeah and and
um uh similar sized cats
uh Jaguar destroy anacondas even in
water which is the anaconda's preferred
domain so
given that
puma and and jaguar are several orders
below lion you have to go with the idea
that a lion would utterly decimate
Anaconda so it's probably good that we
did skip over it and I think uh going
back to the original thought that you
had about this don't trust your first
instinct also think about the other
elements an anaconda has no ability to
disengage from the fight
once the flight's on It's gotta go until
the end it has no ability to disengage
and get away
um its only hope would be Ambush and
it's got
a tiny tiny chance against
yeah a truly formidable animal and the
fact that if we look at actual concrete
real world results when when puma and
jaguar are kicking their ass you know
lion and bear it's going to be a lot
worse
science is not to be found on YouTube or
rather YouTube is not science I bet you
there's a bear
somewhere in Canada that has seen some
[ __ ] I'm just gonna leave it at that
uh you're a fan of knives
there's
guys like Miyamoto Musashi who
instead of doing who's number one type
of tournaments when both competitors
walk away only one competitor walks away
miyamoro Musashi is is known for
somebody having uh John Donahoe like
philosophical
skills but also is known
for uh having fought 61 duels to the
death and won them correct obviously
what do you think made him so good I
don't feel qualified to talk about him
because I haven't made an in-depth study
of his life and times and
um uh we also don't know
how much truth there is to his
Recollections and there's a lot of
controversy over this so I don't feel
like you can give it like a definitive
statement of uh and certainly I can't
give a definitive statement of of
um uh of his prowess but um his writings
are fascinating and deeply insightful
but as to like what actually happened
out there in his deals it's unclear but
there is you know with guys like that
you almost certainly know that they War
people
like the character he projects that have
existed yeah whether it's 61 whether
it's 20 but people really put their life
in the line
in a different time in human history is
there something compelling to you about
fighting to the death I think it's not
just compelling to me but to anyone I
mean there's nothing we value more than
our than our lives and to be able to say
I'm I'm prepared to die
for a sense of Honor things that are so
foreign to our modern society
um imagine you know we criticize people
for something as simple as like road
rage and yet you can imagine someone
who is a sufficiently developed sense of
Honor you know if you took them out of
the 17th century and put them in a
modern car they might be killing people
on the side of the road on a regular
basis just over smaller stacks of honor
to say that your yours your sense of
self overwhelms your sense of
self-preservation it's a very unusual
thing in the Modern Age and yet it
appears to have been quite common back
then
you often wear a fanny pack I'm not
going to ask you what's inside the fanny
pack but if you were to design a perfect
killing machine that also wore a Fanning
pack what would you put
in that fanny pack would it be something
mundane and practical or would it be
something
surprising and hilarious
uh would it be
uh something of philosophical
significance or maybe sentimental
significance or would be empty as a
troll on human civilization but if it
was a perfect killing machine it would
have to be some kind of weapon
but in a fanny pack
is it inward has to be a very compact
weapon
we mentioned Offline that there's also
things in the Chess World where there is
a different kind of vibrating devices
that could be used to uh
communicate information
in communication with AI systems that
can help you in your particular Pursuit
I don't think in Jiu Jitsu you need
is possible for a machine to give you
information that gives you advantage
you can in chess and in poker so you
could put one of those vibrating devices
in your fanny pack playing Jiu Jitsu
would not help you
um
any idea what kind of weapon
fit in a fanny pack
so you're a fan of knives where's the
interesting guys come from by the way oh
that's more metaphorical
um uh the truth is that in the modern
world a knife is not an efficient weapon
it'll easily be overwhelmed by Firearms
um my fascination with with knives comes
more in the sense that they they convey
a spirit to my students where
a knife
is made of steel and steel begins as ore
in the ground it's
an ugly
unfinished product which
through the enactment of knowledge time
and discipline can be transformed into
beautiful shining steel it can have
something which it begins as something
which has no real function and becomes
one of the most functional and important
Tools in all of human history without
which human civilization could never
have even begun it's what separated
humans and took us from the bottom of
the food chain and began our gradual
rise towards the top of the food chain
so it has immense historical and
cultural value but it has this
metaphorical value insofar as the
martial artist begins as a Wipeout like
iron ore but over time transforms into
some beautiful shining Steel
which can have immense value
um
in addition there's a sense of of
Maintenance as remarkable as steel is
it is in need of constant maintenance it
will fall apart through rust and neglect
will destroy a blade both in terms of
rust and the edge falling apart and so
just as the martial artist it's not good
enough just to to learn the techniques
you need to maintain them over time
and just as steel as perishable so too
are the skills of martial arts and that
when I give a gift of a knife to a
student these metaphorical elements
start to emerge they see okay I began as
iron ore and I want to become the
finished blade
um
there's another sense in which
a knife is morally neutral
a knife can be used to Save a Life it
can be used to cook a meal
but it can also be used for murder for
the worst possible purposes
um Jiu Jitsu is the same way
Jiu Jitsu can make you a better person
it can make you a worse person Judas was
just a power it's not a particularly
great power but it is a power and like
all power it can be used for both good
and bad it's morally neutral in itself
and it's up to us to make sure that just
as the knife gets used for good purposes
rather than bad so to let Jiu Jitsu be
used for good purposes rather than bad
there's also an element where
the basis of the knife is steel
and historically there's always been a
riddle of Steel which is
still has the property of both
hardness and suppleness
the harder you make steel
the better it's Edge retention becomes
the longer that edge will stay sharp
this is good but it comes at a price
the harder you make steel the more
brittle it becomes
and now that edge
can be damaged easily
so the solution is to make the steel
softer more malleable that will prevent
breakage of the blade and
chipping of the edge
but when you make the steel softer that
comes at a price and that price is now
the edge loses its uh its its sharpness
very easily
and so
the riddle of Steel is how to
work with these two to the greatest
degree possible and create an edge which
is hard enough to stay sharp for long
periods of time but without making the
steel so brittle that the blade overall
is compromised
so too in Jiu-Jitsu
your task and training is to make the
training competitive enough that you
actually get used to the rigors of of
real Combat
but on the other hand it can't be so
brutal that the athletes get broken down
on the gym to a point where they're no
longer effective
and so this duality of hardness and
softness which we see in the case of
blades is there in the training of the
Jiu Jitsu athlete so I often give a gift
of a knife
to a student when they've done something
significant because it demonstrates in a
metaphorical way these key themes of the
sport
well I've been honored to be
a student of yours I've been plagued by
injury
but I hope to one day earn one such
knife and I think that's a really
powerful metaphor I'm really honored
that you would spend any time with me in
any context but especially on the mat
and especially today in conversation
John you're an incredible person thank
you for everything you do
congratulations
for historic accomplishment it's always
beautiful and inspiring to see greatness
and what what I saw what we saw at ADCC
was greatness rare greatness and it's
beautiful to see that humans can achieve
that kind of thing so thank you for for
making that happen and thank you for
talking today thank you legs
thanks for listening to this
conversation with John donaher to
support this podcast please check out
our sponsors in the description
and now let me leave you some words for
Miyamoto Musashi
the only reason a warrior is alive is
the fight
and the only reason a warrior fights is
to win
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time